JUST IN THE INTEREST OF TIME I
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT WE GET
STARTED ON TIME AND I WANT TO
THINK -- I FIRST I WANT TO WHAT
THE WELCOME -- MY COMMITTEE
MEMBERS AND I KNOW WE'RE ALL
BUSY SO WE'LL HAVE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS COMING IN AND OUT -- AND
A WE REALLY APPRECIATE -- BEING
ABLE TO DO THIS -- AS THE CHAIR
OF THE SELECT COMMITTEE ON
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE.
I KNOW THAT YOU ALL KNOW THAT I
HAVE THIS COMMITTEE IS VERY --
DEAR TO ME BECAUSE I HAVE A
FAMILY MEMBER THAT IS A SURVIVOR
OF DOMESTIC VIOLENCE AND SO WHEN
WE STARTED THIS WORK -- THE
PARTNERSHIP TO INVEST MY LIVES
HAVE BEEN -- WITH ME AS TO
PARTNERS WE'VE BEEN DOING A LOT
OF WORK -- AS WELL AS ARE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS AND ASSEMBLY
MEMBER ELOISE RAISES HERE AND
SHE HAS ALSO BEEN A CHAMPION NOT
ONLY IN THE IN THIS AREA HERE
BUT ALSO IN HER COMMUNITY -- SHE
IS CHAIR OF HUMAN SERVICES AND
THE ACTING CHAIR OF OF HEALTH
AND HUMAN SERVICES SOMEONE
COMMITTEE ON THE BUDGET.
AND IN MY OPINION HAS BEEN DOING
A FANTASTIC JOB ADVOCATING NOT
JUST -- FOR THE ISSUES THAT ARE
IMPORTANT TO THE DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE ARENA BUT ALSO TO
HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES I WANT
TO THANK HER. FOR BEING HERE I
SEE IT AND COMMITTEE WITH HER
AND TO SEE HER WORK SHE'S VERY
DELIBERATE.
IN HER QUESTIONING OF OF THE OF
OUR DEPARTMENTS -- BECAUSE AT
THE END OF THE DAY THESE ARE
VULNERABLE FOLKS THAT NEED OUR
HELP AND SHE'S DONE AN AMAZING
JOB SOMEONE I THINK YOU FOR
BEING HERE.
TODAY.
I'D LIKE ALSO LIKE TO THANK THE
CALIFORNIA PARTNERSHIP TURNED
MYSTIC VIOLENCE FOR ASSISTING MY
STAFF AND HELPING TO PUT THE
HEARING.
TOGETHER TODAY I AM.
A CHAMPION IN MY OPINION FOR
WHEN ADDRESSING THE ISSUES
BECAUSE AGAIN IT'S VERY NEAR AND
DEAR TO MY HEART.
AND I ALSO BELIEVE THAT ARE ROLL
UP IN THE LEGISLATURE'S TO LOOK
OUT FOR THOSE FOLKS THAT CAN
LOOK OUT FOR THEMSELVES -- MANY
OF YOU KNOW -- WELL THIS IS NOT
THE FIRST HEARING THAT WE'VE HAD
WHAT WHAT OUR GOAL IS TO HAVE
ONE HERE I ALSO WANT TO MOVE UP
AND DOWN THE STATE. TO MAKE SURE
THAT -- THE DIFFERENT REGIONS
ARE TO OUR WE HAVE A HEARING IN
THE DIFFERENT REGIONS -- I ALSO
HAVE -- MEMBER BUT JAMES
ROMMEL'S WHO IS THE FIRST NATIVE
AMERICAN -- MEMBER TO BE.
ELECTED TO THE LEGISLATURE AND
HE'S DONE A LOT OF WORK -- FOR
THE NATIVE AMERICAN COMMUNITY
AND IN.
WHO IS WALKING IN RIGHT NOW AND
HE HAS -- EXPRESSED INTEREST IN.
BRINGING -- THE HEARINGS DOWN TO
THE NATIVE AMERICAN COMMUNITY
AND SO I'M VERY THANKFUL FOR HIS
LEADERSHIP AND FOR HIS ADVICE
AND OUR OUR GOAL IS TO HAVE
A ANOTHER HEARING IN THE NATIVE
AMERICAN COMMUNITY WHICH HIM
HE'S NEIGHBOR OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER
ELOISE RADIUS OF WE BRING THE
THE PARTNERSHIP ARE THE DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE HEARING. TO THAT AREA
WE WILL BE ABLE TO BRING IT TO
THE INLAND EMPIRE -- AND I ALSO
STRONGLY BELIEVE THAT PREVENTION
WORKS AND BY ALLOCATING MONEY IN
OUR BUDGET -- THIS YEAR AGAIN
WITH THE PARTNERSHIP AND WE ARE
ASKING FOR ABOUT FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS.
AND WE'RE WORKING THROUGH THAT
WE ASKED FOR FORTY LAST YEAR AND
WE GOT TEN SO WE ASK FOR FIFTY
THIS YEAR.
AND HOPEFULLY WE GET FIFTY BUT
IF WE DON'T WE YOU KNOW WE CAN
WORK ON EVERY YEAR HAVING AN
ALLOCATION TO HELP.
BRING AWARENESS AND PREVENTION I
KNOW WE CAN HAVE MEETINGS AND
CONVERSATIONS ALL WE WANT BUT IF
WE DON'T PUT THOSE ACTIONS INTO
OUR THOSE CONVERSATIONS INTO
ACTION.
THERE WERE BASICALLY JUST HAVING
A CONVERSATION IN THE HOPE IS
THAT IN THE NEXT -- YEAR THAT I
CAN TAKE THE INPUT FROM THE CAN
THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS AND THE
INPUT ROM THE ORGANIZATIONS
THAT ARE INTERESTED IN THAT BAD
ADVOCATE FOR SURVIVORS.
AND WE CAN PUT SOME POP POLICIES
TOGETHER SO I WANT YOU TO THINK
ABOUT THE CONVERSATION TODAY IN
TERMS OF ANY LEGISLATION THAT WE
POSSIBLY CAN INTRODUCED THE
FOLLOWING YEAR.
SO THIS IS A CONVERSATION BUT
WHEN WE ARE LOOKING AT THIS
PLEASE LOOK AT IT IN THE WHAT
CAN WE DO.
ADD LEGISLATIVELY SO THAT WE CAN
INTRODUCE SOME OF THOSE IDEAS
INTO SOME POLICIES NEXT YEAR.
AGAIN I WANT TO WELCOME ASSEMBLY
MEMBER RAMOS ASSEMBLY MEMBER --
ASSEMBLY WOMAN AYE LOUISE RAY AS
AN ASSEMBLY MEMBER GIPSON -- TO
TO THE HEARING AND THAT THIS
POINT IF YOU HAVE ANY COMMENTS
THAT YOU WOULD LIKE TO START
WITH PLEASE -- GO AHEAD AND
DECIDE THIS TIME.
THE MADAM CHAIR -- I THINK THIS
SELECT COMMITTEE IS EXTREMELY
IMPORTANT AND YOU'RE RIGHT YOU
YOU'VE HAD SOME PARTNERS BACK IN
THE COMMUNITY -- ON THE ISSUE OF
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE I THINK THAT'S
REALLY IMPORTANT WELL ONE OF
THOSE PARTNERS IS NOW SITTING IN
THE LEGISLATURE AND THAT'S YOUR
SISTER CENTER -- SUSAN RUBIO.
AND THAT'S IT.
I THINK IT IT TELLS US THAT WHEN
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT A TOPIC
THAT IS SO IMPORTANT TO THE
COMMUNITY THEN YOU'RE ABLE TO DO
SO MUCH MORE -- THE TOPIC OF
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE.
OFTENTIMES IS A VERY PAINFUL ONE
TO DISCUSS AND SO I WANT TO
THANK EVERYONE FOR BEING HERE.
TO HAVE THESE CRITICAL
CONVERSATIONS THAT ARE SO
NECESSARY.
I AM DEEPLY DISTURBED BY THE
PREVAILING SO VIOLENCE AGAINST
YOUNG GIRLS AND WOMEN IN THE
STATE.
AND I'M COMMITTED.
TO WITH YOU MADAM CHAIR TO
WORKING WITH THIS COMMUTE THIS
COMMITTEE TO BRING CLARITY IN
ACTION TO IMPROVE THE CURRENT
CULTURE.
EARLIER THIS YEAR I WAS
ABSOLUTELY SHOCKED TO FIND OUT
THE DURING A PERIOD OF ALMOST
THREE DECADES.
MORE THAN FOURTEEN THOUSAND
YOUNG WOMEN.
HAD BEEN SEXUALLY EXPLOITED --
SEXUALLY.
EXPLOITED I'M GOING TO USE THAT
WORD.
BY DOCTOR TENDO A LONG TIME
GYNECOLOGIST AT U. S. C. WHO IS
THERE FOR ALMOST THIRTY YEARS.
HE HARASSED ALL THESE WOMEN BUT
HE SPECIFICALLY TARGETED WOMEN
OF COLOR.
AND IMMIGRANT WOMEN.
THE INTERNATIONAL STUDENTS.
THEY WERE IN FACT THE MOST
VULNERABLE POPULATION.
I'VE INTRODUCED AB FIFTEEN TAN
IN RESPONSE TO THIS MY HOPE TO
REOPEN THE STATUTE OF
LIMITATIONS.
THAT IS ALREADY EXPIRED AND THEN
TO ALLOW THE SURVIVORS TO SUBMIT
THEIR CLAIM TO COURT IF THEY SO
CHOOSE.
IT'S THE UNFORTUNATE REALITY
REALITY THAT I HAVE TO AUTHORS
SUCH A BILL A WE SHOULD BE
BEYOND ALL OF THIS -- BUT IT WAS
NECESSARY LEGISLATION IN MY
OPINION BECAUSE THE ACTS THAT
OCCURRED OCCURRED OVER SUCH A
LONG PERIOD OF TIME.
WE KNOW THE PREVENTION IS
CRITICAL. TO STOPPING THESE
EGREGIOUS ACTS AND I APPLAUD YOU
FOR ALL THE WORK THAT YOU DO AND
MAKING SURE THAT THE BUDGET
REFLECTS OUR OUR VALUES.
AND MAKING SURE THAT YOU YOU
JOIN WITH THOSE WHO ARE
REQUESTING THAT THE BUDGET
REFLECT THE AMOUNT OF MONEY IT'S
NEVER GOING TO BE ENOUGH.
AND I'VE YOU'VE YOU'VE SAID THIS
MANY TIMES BUT TO BE SURE THAT
THE THE THE THE THE REQUEST IS
MADE I DO LOOK FORWARD TO BEING
PART OF THIS SEC SELECT
COMMITTEE.
AND I THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
CONVENING IT TODAY.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR THANK YOU
FOR SHARING THIS SELECT
COMMITTEE ON THIS A VERY
IMPORTANT.
AREA A DOMESTIC VIOLENCE AND
SEXUAL ASSAULT PREVENTION AND
THESE TYPES OF THINGS HAPPEN
ACROSS THROUGHOUT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA ACROSS ALL
ETHNICITIES AND AND AND IT'S
SOMETHING THAT WE NEED TO COME
TOGETHER AND AND TAKE A STAND TO
SHOW THAT THOSE THAT.
HAVE.
BEEN THROUGH THESE TYPES OF
SITUATIONS KNOW THAT WE ARE IN
SUPPORT AND TRYING TO GET ON
RESOURCES TO TO MOVE FORWARD
WITH A LIFE AND HOLDING THOSE
THAT PERPETRATED IT.
AGAINST THEM ACCOUNTABLE FOR
THEIR ACTIONS ALSO.
AND MANAGER I WALKED IN WHEN
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT THE NATIVE
AMERICAN POPULATION WE JUST
MOVED ON THE FLOOR -- FOR MAKING
MAY -- AWARENESS FOR MISSING AND
MURDERED INDIGENOUS SO WOMEN --
IN THE NATION BUT IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA THERE'S A HIGH
POPULATION -- AND IT'S NUMBER
SIX ON THE LIST SO THIS IS VERY --
TIMELY AS FAR AS MAKING SURE
THAT WE'RE ADDRESSING THESE
ISSUES IN HEARING FROM THOSE
THAT ARE HERE TO SPEAK TO THE
ISSUE TO FORMULATE LEGISLATION --
IN THE FUTURE SO WE'RE LOOKING
FORWARD TO THIS AND THANK YOU
FOR ASSEMBLY IN THE SELECT
COMMITTEE -- THANK YOU VERY MUCH
GOOD MORNING TO YOU -- EACH AND
EVERYONE OF YOU -- I WANT TO SAY
FIRST OF ALL TO OUR OUR
CHAIRWOMAN THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR CONVENING THIS IMPORTANT.
AND MUCH NECESSARY I'M
CONVERSATION ON DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE AND SEXUAL ASSAULT
PREVENTION -- LIKE MY COLLEAGUES
WHO ALREADY SAID WE AYE ECHO --
THE COMMENTS THEY HAVE ALREADY
MADE THIS IS A VERY IMPORTANT
ISSUE -- IN OUR COMMUNITY IN
CALIFORNIA -- I JUST RE WAS
REFLECTING ON SO MY TIME WHEN I
WAS A POLICE OFFICER IN THE CITY
OF MAY WOOD.
AND GOING TO A HOME WHERE A
HUSBAND JAZZ VIOLATED HIS WIFE
AND OT PHYSICAL AND HOW ANGRY I
BECAME AS A RESULT OF OF THAT
SITUATION.
AND SO WE REALIZE THAT WE MUST
CHANGE -- THE TRAJECTORY AND
PEOPLE'S MINDS THAT -- STARTING
AT AN ADOLESCENT AGE THAT
BULLYING IS NOT ACCEPTABLE --
BUT ALSO TO LET -- THOSE HERE
KNOW THAT -- WILL -- THOSE WHO
ARE VICTIMS ARE NOT JUST WOMEN
MEN ALSO OUR VICTIM AND ALSO
SHOULD HAVE THEIR PLACE IN THE
CONVERSATION -- BECAUSE
SOMETIMES A LOT OF VIOLENCE WITH
THAT MEN SUFFER GOES UNREPORTED
BECAUSE OF THE STIGMA YOU POST
BE A MAN SUCK IT UP YOU KNOW AND
THINGS OF THAT NATURE.
AND SO WE MUST REMEMBER THAT MAN
ALSO ARE VICTIMS OF DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE -- AS WELL AND SO I'M
HAPPY WANT TO SEE -- ONE OF THE
GROUPS THAT I REPRESENTS --
BELIEVES THE CITY IN WHICH I
REPRESENT LONG BEACH LGBT US
CENTER OF LONG BEACH IS IS HERE
IN REPRESENTATIVE ADD THEIR
VOICES -- WITH ALL THAT WHO WILL
COME AND TESTIFY SO I'M HAPPY TO
BE HERE I'M LOOKING FORWARD TO
THEIR ROBUST CONVERSATION AS WE
MOVE FOR SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU I'M YES -- THANK YOU --
FOR FOR BEING HERE BUT ALSO I
DID WANT -- TO TALK ABOUT
SENATOR SUSAN RUBIO WHO'S BEST
SAID IN THE LEGISLATURE NOW --
AND AS A SURVIVOR OF DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE SHE'S DOING SOME WORK
ON THE OTHER SIDE AND I DON'T
WANT TO FEEL -- HEARD THUNDER --
BECAUSE SHE IS VERY OBVIOUSLY
MORE VERY PASSIONATE ABOUT THE
ISSUE AND SHE'S GOT A PIECE OF A
COUPLE PIECES OF LEGISLATION.
ON THE OTHER SIDE AND I AND THE
NEXT -- HOPEFULLY THE NEXT
HEARING WE WE CAN HEAR FROM HER
AND HOW THE LEGISLATION IS GOING --
BUT I'VE ALSO PARTNERED WITH
SENATOR BAIL -- DO AS WE DID
LAST YEAR TO TO REQUEST A FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS -- FOR SIX
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE AND SEXUAL
ASSAULT PART OF THE CONVERSATION
THAT THE SENATORS HASN'T SENATOR
SUSAN RUBIO HAS HAD -- IS ABOUT
THE PREVENTION AND ABOUT HEALTHY
RELATIONSHIPS -- SHE AND I HAD --
ANY DENT IN OUR DISTRICT -- FOR
YOUNG WOMEN AND WHEN WE TALKED
ABOUT -- HEALTHY RELATIONSHIPS
ONE OF THE ISSUES THAT CAME UP
WITH THE YOUNG FOLKS WAS THAT
THEY DIDN'T REALIZE THAT HEALTHY
RELATIONSHIPS THEY NECESSARILY
MEAN TO ME TO BE ROMANTIC
RELATIONSHIPS.
BECAUSE WE TALK ABOUT THEM AS
THE VIOLENCE IN TERMS OF OF A
ROMANTIC PARTNERS -- THE SPOUSES
AND GIRLFRIENDS AND BOYFRIENDS
BUT THE REALITY IS AND THE THE
YOUNG WOMEN POINTED THAT OUT IS
THAT THEY THOUGHT.
THE SAME THING BUT WHEN WE HAD A
CONVERSATION WITH THEM WE ALSO
FOUND OUT THAT IT DOESN'T HAVE
TO BE.
A ROMANTIC PARTNER YOU CAN BE --
VIOLATED OUR BULLIED BY BY
FRIENDS AND THAT'S HOW THE CYCLE
OF THE OF DOMESTIC OF YOU'D BE
STARTS IF YOU ALLOW OTHER PEOPLE.
TO TO TO BULLY YOU VIOLATE YOU --
EVEN IF IT'S NOT ROMANTICALLY
THEN WHEN YOU GET INTO A
RELATIONSHIP A ROMANTIC
RELATIONSHIP YOU DON'T KNOW THE
DIFFERENCE AND YOU ASSUME THAT
THAT'S ALSO.
OKAY EVEN IF YOUR GUT TELLS YOU
THAT IT'S NOT OKAY AND SO IS
VERY -- EYE OPENING FOR ME
BECAUSE WE TALK ABOUT DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE IN TERMS OF ROMANTIC
PARTNERS -- BY THE CYCLE STARTS
WITH OTHER RELATIONSHIPS THAT
ARE NOT HEALTHY AND SO I WANT TO
THANK ALL OF YOU FOR BEING HERE --
AND I WANT.
TO BRING UP OUR NEXT PANEL AND
AGAIN I THINK THE PANEL MEMBERS
WILL BRING YOU UP -- WILL HAVE
ABOUT HALF AN HOUR OF DISCUSSION --
AND THEN A QUESTIONS AND ANSWERS
ARE FROM THE COMMITTEE AND
POSSIBLY FROM THE PUBLIC AND
THEN WE'LL MOVE ON TO THE THE
FOLLOWING PANEL OUR GOAL IS TO
BE OUT HERE BY -- ELEVEN THIRTY
AND I WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
KEEP TO THAT TIME JUST SO THAT
WE CAN BE A THIS F. AS EFFICIENT
AS POSSIBLE.
SO THANK YOU AGAIN AND I WOULD
LIKE TO BRING -- OUR FIRST PANEL
UP -- WE HAVE YOU SEE HERE.
KIRSTEN RAMBO I'M SORRY THAT'S
THE THE SECOND PANEL.
OUR FIRST PANEL.
THE FIRST PANEL HERE HOLD ON WE
FIND MY MY NOTES.
YES I'M SORRY.
THANK YOU.
SO OUR FIRST PANEL -- IS AUDREY
DAVIS PROGRAM COORDINATOR FOR
ALLIANCE FOR COMMUNITY
TRANSFORMATIONS MOUNTAIN CRISIS
SERVICES IN MY OPPOSE IF YOU
WOULD LIKE TO COME UP. TO TO THE
DíAS PLEASE AND THEN -- SERWIS
ALL OF AN EDUCATION AND OUTREACH
PROGRAM COORDINATOR -- CATALYST
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE SERVICES IN
CHICO AND MELODY.
OF COURSE BY THE END OF
PREVENTION AND POLICY DIVISION
DIRECTOR PEACE OVER VIOLENCE IN
LOS ANGELES.
THANK YOU WELCOME AND THERE'S
SOME -- NAME PLATES IF YOU WOULD
LIKE.
TO AB RIGHT IN FRONT OF YOU JUST
SAW THAT TO A WE KNOW.
WHO WE ARE DRESSING THANK YOU
[inaudible]
THANK [inaudible]
THANK YOU -- IF WE CAN START THE
CONVERSATION AUDREY -- IF YOU
WOULD LIKE TO START OKAY THANK
YOU GOOD MORNING.
MY NAME IS AUDREY DAVIS AND I
THANK YOU.
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO BE HERE
TODAY AND SPEAK ABOUT PREVENTION
WORK WITH YOUTH.
I ENJOY WORKING WITH YOUTH AND
MY ROLE AS A PROGRAM COORDINATOR
FOR ETHOS YOUTH CENTER.
WHICH IS LOCATED IN MARIPOSA
CALIFORNIA.
WERE PART OF A LARGER
ORGANIZATION THE ALLIANCE FOR
COMMUNITY TRANSFORMATIONS.
WHICH ALSO HAS DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
AND SEXUAL ASSAULT PROGRAMS IN
MARIPOSA AND MERCED.
THOUGH OUR COMMUNITIES ARE SMALL
AND RURAL VIOLENCE STILL HAPPENS
IN OUR HOMES AND IN OUR SCHOOLS.
OUR ORGANIZATION HAS BEEN DOING
PREVENTION WORK AND MAYOR POSTS
AND MERCED FOR MANY YEARS AND
IT'S HAD A POSITIVE IMPACT.
BECAUSE I'VE BEEN WORKING IN OUR
PROGRAMS FOR OVER FIVE YEARS
I'VE BEEN ABLE TO SEE CHANGES IN
THE COMMUNITY.
AND THREE EVALUATING SOME OF OUR
EFFORTS I HAVE DOCUMENTED
INCREASES IN KNOWLEDGE MESSAGING
AWARENESS AND EDUCATION.
HAVE WE A RADIC HATED VIOLENCE
ALL TOGETHER.
NO.
BUT HAVE WE HELP THE COMMUNITY
TO LEARN TO RECOGNIZE SEXUAL
VIOLENCE I WOULD SAY ABSOLUTELY
YES.
A SPECIFIC EXAMPLE OF THIS IS
THECOMMUNITY IT RESPONDING
APPROPRIATELY IT TO
INAPPROPRIATE SEXUAL BEHAVIOR.
TWO YEARS AGO THIS TYPE OF
INCIDENT MAY HAVE BEEN
OVERLOOKED OR CHALKED UP TO JUST
SOMETHING THAT HAPPENS.
BUT WITH MORE EDUCATION AND
AWARENESS ABOUT WHAT SEXUAL
ASSAULT IS.
THERE ARE MORE PEOPLE SPEAKING
OUT AND REACTING TO HOLD PEOPLE
ACCOUNTABLE.
THE WAYS THAT WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO
WORK WITH FAMILIES AND WITHIN
OUR EDUCATION SYSTEM HAS HELPED
TO CREATE CHANGES SUCH AS
ADVOCATING FOR INDIVIDUALS ARE
ENCOURAGING SCHOOL POLICY
CHANGES.
SO I WILL TALK A LITTLE BIT MORE
ABOUT SOME OF THE LARGER
PREVENTION EFFORTS THAT I'VE
BEEN FORTUNATE TO BE A PART OF
OVER THE PAST FEW YEARS.
WHEN I FIRST BEGAN DOING
PREVENTION WORK AMONG CRISIS
SERVICES IN MARIPOSA?
WE WERE ONE YEAR INTO A FIVE
YEAR GRANT FROM THE CDC IN THE
GRANT HELPED US TO FOCUS ON A
COMMUNITY LEVEL CHANGE.
BY CREATING MESSAGING AROUND
ADOLESCENT RELATIONSHIP ABUSE
PREVENTION AND ENCOURAGING OUR
COMMUNITY TO THINK OF SCHOOLS AS
PLACES WHERE.
HEALTHY RELATIONSHIPS BEGAN.
AND WE'RE HEALTHY RELATIONSHIP
SKILLS CAN BE TAUGHT AND TALKED
ABOUT.
IN ADDITION TO CREATING AND
DISSEMINATING MESSAGING AROUND
THIS ISSUE WE ALSO DEVELOP
POLICY GUIDELINES FOR OUR SCHOOL
DISTRICT TO CONSIDER AS WELL AS
SCHOOL SITE LEVEL CHANGES THAT
COULD BE PRACTICES. TO PROMOTE
HEALTHY RELATIONSHIPS SUCH AS
ENCOURAGING SCHOOLS TO HIRE A
COUNSELOR FOR EACH SCHOOL SITE
PROVIDING TRAINING FOR ALL STAFF
AND RECOGNIZING AND RESPONDING
TO RELATIONSHIP ABUSE.
WE WERE ABLE TO EVALUATE OUR
EFFORTS AND MEASURE INCREASES IN
OUR PARTNERSHIPS WITH COMMUNITY
MEMBERS SPECIFICALLY WITHIN THE
SCHOOL SYSTEM.
WE ARE ABLE TO MEASURE AN
INCREASE AND MESSAGING ABOUT
HEALTHY RELATIONSHIPS THAT WAS
NOT ONLY COMING FROM US BUT FROM
OTHERS WHO ARE SHARING OUR
MESSAGES.
THAT INCREASE HELPED US TO SEE
THAT THE COMMUNITY SUPPORTED OUR
MESSAGING IN THAT THEY BELIEVED
IT WAS IMPORTANT FOR SCHOOLS TO
TEACH AND TALK ABOUT HEALTHY
RELATIONSHIPS.
THE LASTING IMPACTS OF THIS
PROJECT HAVE.
INCLUDED BETTER RELATIONSHIPS
WITH COMMUNITY PARTNERS WITHIN
THE SCHOOL SYSTEM AND BEYOND
MORE YOU FLAT ACTIVITIES THAT
ARE FOCUSED ON HEALTHY
RELATIONSHIPS SUCH AS THE YEARLY
PERFORMANCE EVENT.
A YOUTH ACTION COMMITTEE AND A
REGULAR MONTHLY COLUMN IN OUR
LOCAL NEWSPAPER.
THE YOUTH PERFORMANCE EVENTS
STARTED AS A SPARSELY ATTENDED
CHAU SPOKEN WORD POETRY THAT A
FEW YOU THROW AND PERFORMED.
AND THE IDEA FOR THAT EVENT WAS
TO HEAR FROM YOU WITHIN THEIR
OWN WORDS ABOUT THEIR IDEAS OF
HEALTHY RELATIONSHIPS AND HOW
ADULTS COULD SUPPORT THEM.
IT GREW OVER THE YEARS AND
FEATURED DIGITAL ART AND AUDIO
DRAMAS ALL CREATED BY YOUTH AND
CENTER ON THE IDEA OF HEALTHY
RELATIONSHIPS.
AND AFTER ABOUT THREE YEARS THE
HIGH SCHOOL DECIDED TO CONVERT
THE SHOW TO BE ONE OF THEIR
REGULAR PERFORMANCES -- NOW THE
SHOW'S CALLED YOUTH VOICES ROCK
AND RIGHT AND STUDENTS RAPE
SCENES INSPIRED BY MUSIC
STUDENTS THAN DIRECT AND PERFORM
THE SCENES AND YOUTH BANDS
PERFORM THE SONGS.
ALTHOUGH IT TOOK SOME TIME THE
SHOW GREW FROM A FEW PEOPLE IN
THE AUDIENCE TO BEING A SOLD OUT
SHOW FOR FOR TWO NIGHTS.
WE NOW HAVE A PLATFORM THAT
REACHES A LOT OF PEOPLE.
OF THE READERSHIP OF OUR
NEWSPAPERS AROUND A THOUSAND
PEOPLE WHICH IS A LOT FOR HER
SMALL COMMUNITY.
AND WE HAVE THIS REGULAR COLUMN
SO WE CAN SHARE OUR PROGRESS AND
PREVENTION OTHER SUCCESSES FROM
OUR PROGRAMS.
OUR CURRENT PREVENTION WORK IS
AIMED AT CREATING PROTECTIVE
ENVIRONMENTS ONCE AGAIN WE'VE
DECIDED TO FOCUS OUR WORK ON
SCHOOLS AS PLACES FOR LEARNING
SKILLS FRUITION SHIPS AND FOR
CREATING POSITIVE SCHOOL
COMMUNITIES AND CLIMATE.
WERE IMPLEMENTING AN EVIDENCE
BASED PROGRAM CALLED SHIFTING
BOUNDARIES WHICH NOT ONLY
TEACHES MIDDLE SCHOOL STUDENTS
SKILLS FOR RESPECTING BOUNDARIES
AND PERSONAL SPACE.
AND HOW TO BECOME ADVOCATES FOR
THEIR OWN SAFETY BUT IT ALSO
GIVES STUDENTS AN OPPORTUNITY TO
EVALUATE THEIR SCHOOL SAFETY AND
ENVIRONMENT THROUGH A HOT SPOT
MAPPING ACTIVITY IN.
WE'VE EMPLOYMENT OF THIS PROGRAM
IN ALL OF OUR DISTRICTS MIDDLE
SCHOOLS AND ARE PLANNING TO
CONTINUE THE PROGRAM FOR THE
NEXT FOUR YEARS OR MORE.
THE OUTCOME SO FAR INCLUDE
REACHING AROUND FIVE HUNDRED
STUDENTS.
HELPING THEM TO UNDERSTAND WHAT
PERSONAL BOUNDARIES ARE ALL
ABOUT.
BEING ABLE TO IDENTIFY NEEDED
CHANGES THAT EACH SCHOOL STATE
BASED ON STUDENT RESPONSES AND
CONTINUING TO BUILD OUR
RELATIONSHIPS WITH LEADERS IN
THE EDUCATION SYSTEM.
SO THAT WE MAY CONTINUE TO
SUPPORT POSITIVE CHANGES WITHIN
THAT SYSTEM.
THERE'S SO MUCH MORE THAT I
COULD SAY ABOUT THE POSITIVE
IMPACTS OF PREVENTION OUR
COMMUNITY WE HAVE A DROP IN
CENTER OR YOUTH CAN GO AFTER
SCHOOL TO BE SAFE PLAY GAMES
LISTEN TO MUSIC DO ART PROJECTS
AND TALK WITH ADULTS.
AND THEIR PEERS ABOUT SOME OF
THE CHALLENGES THEY MAY BE
FACING.
WE TEACH A LIFE SKILLS CLASS OUR
ALTERNATIVE SCHOOL ONCE A WEEK
WHICH GIVES US ANOTHER
OPPORTUNITY TO CONNECT WITH
YOUTH WHO HAD MANY CHALLENGING
CIRCUMSTANCES IN THEIR LIVES.
WE MEET WEEKLY AT A GIRLS GROUP
HOME AND DO ART WHICH HELPS THEM
TO COPE WITH THE STRESS OF BEING
AWAY FROM HOME AND THEIR FAMILY
IS.
THE WE'RE DOING IT SO MUCH
PREVENTION WE'VE HAD HAD SUCCESS
AND BEEN ABLE TO SEE CHANGE OVER
THE PAST SEVERAL YEARS.
MORE FUNDING FOR PREVENTION IN
OUR COMMUNITY WOULD ALLOW US TO
CONTINUE THE WORK WE'RE DOING AN
INCREASE OUR CAPACITY TO DO MORE.
WE ONLY HAVE A FEW STAFF WORKING
PRIMARILY ON PREVENTION AND THEY
WORK HARD.
LONG HOURS AND WEEKENDS.
IT'S DIFFICULT TO SAY NO. TO
THINGS IN THIS FIELD BECAUSE WE
DON'T WANT TO MISS ANY
OPPORTUNITY IS SO WE END UP
BEING SPREAD VERY THIN
[inaudible]
BUT BECAUSE WE KNOW WHAT WORKS
WE KEEP WORKING AT IT AND WHEN
WE LEARN OF OUR SUCCESSES IT
MAKES US WANT TO WORK HARDER.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR GIVING
ME THE TIME TO SPEAK TODAY AND
TO SHARE SOME OF THE WORK WE'RE
DOING.
THANK YOU I'M BEFORE WE CONTINUE
I JUST ONE AND YOU MENTIONED
THAT YOU GOT A GRANT FROM CDC --
CAN YOU TELL ME WHAT THE AMOUNT
OF THE GRANT IS.
THE AMOUNT FOR OUR PROGRAM IS
EIGHTY THOUSAND DOLLARS -- AND
WITH THE AND IT'S YEAH IT'S
DISPERSED TO OUR PROGRAM AND
ANOTHER PROGRAM IN CALIFORNIA --
SO THE TOTAL AMOUNT OF AND ALSO
THROUGH THE CALIFORNIA
PARTNERSHIP AND DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE SO THE TOTAL NUMBER IS
LARGER THAN THAT BUT IT IS A
FIVE YEAR GRANT SO WE HAVE A
FULL TIME STAFF PERSON WORKING
ON THAT GRANT AND THEN A COUPLE
OF OTHER -- STAFF WHO WORK.
A FEW HOURS ON THAT GRANT AS
WELL [inaudible]
BUT YEAH IT IS THROUGH THE CDC
SO IT'S NOT CALIFORNIA STATE
FUNDING AND IT'S AN AWESOME
FUNDING SOURCE FOR US BUT IT'S
YEAH NOT FROM.
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA AT THIS
POINT BECAUSE YEAH IT SEEMS LIKE
YOU'RE YOU'RE ACCESSING --
MONIES YOU KNOW WE SEEM TO THINK
THAT.
WHY LEAST I DO THAT CALIFORNIA
HAS TO FIND IT BUT THE CDC?
YOU KNOW IF WE CAN ACCESS SOME
OF THOSE GRANTS THAT MIGHT HELP
ME IN OAK DUPLICATOR PROGRAM IT
SOUNDS LIKE IT'S A FANTASTIC
PROGRAM.
SO THANK YOU WE CAN YOU KNOW
TALK A LITTLE BIT MORE AFTERWARD
BY JUSTIN WAS INTERESTED IN THE
AMOUNT YEAH THANK YOU THANK YOU
AND THEN I HI.
HOW MANY MISTER SOLOMON AND I AM
THE EDUCATION OUT REACH PROGRAM
COORDINATOR AT CATALYST DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE SERVICES IN BUTTE
COUNTY?
I AM VERY HAPPY TO BE HERE TODAY.
FIRST I'D LIKE TO THINK MEMBERS
OF THIS COMMITTEE FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK WITH YOU I
LIKE TO ESPECIALLY THANK
ASSEMBLY MEMBER AND COMMITTEE
CHAIR BLANCA RUBIO FOR YOUR
LEADERSHIP AND COMMITMENT TO
THIS ISSUE.
TALKING ABOUT INTIMATE PARTNER
VIOLENCE IS HARD.
IT IS UNCOMFORTABLE AT TIMES
SCARY TO THINK ABOUT OUR LOVED
ONES BEING HARMED BY SOMEONE
THEY LOVE AND TRUST.
PREVENTION EFFORTS BRING A
HISTORICALLY PRIVATE
CONVERSATION TO THE PUBLIC EYE
AND THAT CAN FEEL TABOO.
BUT TALKING ABOUT IT OPENLY AND
HONESTLY IS THE FIRST STEP TO
PREVENTING IT FROM HAPPENING TO
FUTURE GENERATIONS.
THANK YOU ALL FOR BEING WILLING
TO ENGAGE IN THESE TOUGH
CONVERSATIONS AND FOR ADVOCATING
FOR CHANGE.
I HAVE WORK TO CATALYST MYSTIC
VIOLENCE SERVICES FOR ALMOST
FOUR YEARS I AM AN ADVOCATE A
COMMUNITY EDUCATOR AND A
SUPERVISOR.
THE MISSION OF CATALYST IS
REDUCE THE INCIDENCE OF INTIMATE
PARTNER VIOLENCE THROUGH CRISIS
INTERVENTION SERVICES COMMUNITY
EDUCATION AND THE PROMOTION OF
HEALTHY RELATIONSHIPS.
I HAVE THE PRIVILEGE OF WORKING
WITH YOUNG PEOPLE AND ADULTS TO
EDUCATE THEM ABOUT RED FLAGS OF
ABUSE AND GIVE THEM THE TOOLS
THEY NEED TO ENGAGE IN HEALTHY
RELATIONSHIPS.
BOTH ROMANTICALLY AND PLATONIC
LAME.
I WORK WITH MY TEAM TO DEVELOP
INNOVATIVE CURRICULUM BASED ON
BEST PRACTICES TO ADDRESS THE
MERE OUT OF ISSUES ARE YOUNG
PEOPLE ARE FACING TODAY WHEN
TRYING TO NAVIGATE NEW
RELATIONSHIPS.
MANY OF THEM HAVE NEVER HAD
HEALTHY COMMUNICATION MODEL THAT
HOME AND STRUGGLE TO UNDERSTAND
HOW TO ENGAGE IN HEALTHY
BEHAVIOR.
I AM PROUD TO SAY THAT DURING
THE 200-017-22000 EIGHTEEN
FISCAL YEAR OUR TEAM REACH TWO
THOUSAND FOUR HUNDRED NINETY TO
USE.
WE FACILITATED TWO HUNDRED AND
EIGHTEEN PRESENTATIONS AND WE
PARTICIPATED IN FIFTY TWO
COMMUNITY EVENTS.
WE KNOW THAT WITH MORE FINANCIAL
SUPPORT OUR EFFORTS WOULD REACH
EVEN MORE PEOPLE.
SOMETIMES DIRECT SERVICE WORK
CAN FEEL OVERWHELMING AND MAYBE
EVEN A LITTLE HOPE LESS.
WE KNOW THAT ONE IN THREE PEOPLE
WILL EXPERIENCE VIOLENCE IN A
RELATIONSHIP AT SOME POINT IN
THEIR LIVES.
THAT IS A STAGGERING NUMBER.
WE ALSO KNOW THAT IT TAKES AN
AVERAGE OF SEVEN TIMES TO LEAVE
AN ABUSIVE PARTNER.
BUT THERE IS LIGHT AT THE END OF
THE TUNNEL.
PREVENTION BRINGS HOPE TO THE
CHALLENGING IN OFTENTIMES
DEVASTATING WORK THAT WE DO
EVERY DAY WITH VICTIMS.
BY BEING BRAVE ENOUGH TO HAVE
THESE CONVERSATIONS WITH YOUNG
PEOPLE WE ARE ABLE TO ELIMINATE
THE STIGMA ASSOCIATED WITH
EXPERIENCING ABUSE AND EMPOWER
THEM TO BREAK THE
INTERGENERATIONAL CYCLE OF ABUSE.
WE ALSO KNOW THAT WILL IT WILL
TAKE A LONG TIME BEFORE WE SEE A
SUBSTANTIAL DECREASE AND
INSTANCES OF DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
AND BUTTE COUNTY.
HOWEVER I CAN TELL YOU THAT WE
HAVE ALREADY SEEMS SUCCESS AND
OUR WORK.
WE SEE SUCCESS WHEN STUDENTS
WERE WORK WE'RE WORKING WITH
HAVE THAT LABEL MOMENT.
WHEN WHAT WE'RE SAYING WITH THEM
WHAT WE'RE SAYING REALLY CLICKS
WITH THEM?
WE SEE SUCCESS WHEN AFTER
PRESENTING TO A HIGH SCHOOL
CLASS WE RECEIVE A PHONE CALL
FROM A TEACHER THAT A STUDENT
WOULD LIKE TO TALK WITH US ABOUT
THEIR RELATIONSHIP AND DEVELOP
WAYS TO STAY SAFE.
WE SIXTIES SUCCESS WHEN STUDENTS
AFFIRM THEIR COMMITMENT TO
HEALTHY COMMUNICATION BY SHARING
THE FAIR ARGUMENT RULES WITH
THEIR PARTNERS AND FAMILIES. FOR
THESE REASONS AND MANY MORE I AM
PASSIONATE ABOUT PREVENTION. ONE
OF OUR PREVENTION EFFORTS I AM
MOST PROUD OF IS OUR ANNUAL
YOUTH EMPOWERED CONFERENCE.
THIS PROGRAM IS DESIGNED TO
EDUCATE INFLUENTIAL EIGHTH
GRADERS AND YOU COUNTY ON WAYS
TO BE ACTIVE BYSTANDERS IN
SITUATIONS LIKE BOWLING DATING
ABUSE SEXUAL ASSAULT HAZING AND
DISCRIMINATION.
AS THEY GET READY TO START HIGH
SCHOOL.
THE RISK FACTORS PROTECTED Và
FACTORS AND LONG AND SHORT TERM
CONSEQUENCES OF BULLYING AND
TEEN DATING ABUSE ARE VERY
SIMILAR.
THIS CONFERENCE PROVIDES
OPPORTUNITIES FOR EERS TO BE A
POSITIVE INFLUENCE CREATE
CONNECTIONS IN THE COMMUNITY AND
COMMIT TO REDUCE THE LIKELIHOOD
OF BOTH BULLYING AND TEEN DATING
ABUSE AND THEIR SCHOOLS.
THIS YEAR WE HAD STUDENTS FROM
LAST YEAR'S CONFERENCE COME BACK
AS PURE FACILITATORS THIS
PROVIDED THE OPPORTUNITY FOR
YOUTH LEADERSHIP AND PEER TO
PEER PROGRAMMING.
BYSTANDER INTERVENTION IS A
REALISTIC AND REASONABLE
APPROACH PREVENTION.
WHILE PREVENTING ALL ACTS OF
SEXUAL ON DOMESTIC VIOLENCE FROM
EVER OCCURRING CAN SOMETIMES
FEEL OUT OF REACH CREATING
ENVIRONMENTS IN WHICH PEOPLE WHO
MIGHT HARM OTHERS DO NOT BELIEVE
THEY CAN GET AWAY WITH IT.
IS ATTAINABLE.
CHOOSING A STEP IN CAN AFFECT
HOW OTHERS AROUND US THINK ABOUT
AND RESPOND TO HARMFUL BEHAVIORS.
THAT'S WHY WE WORK WITH SCHOOL
COUNSELORS AND ASK THEM TO
NOMINATE STUDENTS FOR THIS
CONFERENCE WERE SEEN AS LEADERS
AMONG THEIR PEERS STUDENTS WHOSE
VOICES ARE RESPECTED.
WE GET THE STUDENTS IN A ROOM
TOGETHER AND WE ENCOURAGE THEM
TO FEEL RESPONSIBLE FOR THE
PROTECTION SAFETY OF THEIR PEERS
USE THEIR VOICES FOR POSITIVE
CHANGE AN ACT AS ROLE MODELS.
AT FIRST WHEN STUDENTS ARRIVE AT
THE CONFERENCE THEY'RE A LITTLE
GUARDED AND MAYBE EVEN A LITTLE
SKEPTICAL.
BUT ONCE WE'VE GOTTEN THEM TO
TAKE OFF THEIR COOL JACKETS THE
TRANSFORMATION THROUGHOUT THE
DAY IS REMARKABLE.
STUDENTS MEET NEW PEOPLE GET OUT
OF THEIR COMFORT ZONES AND
CONNECT ABOUT THE HARDSHIPS THEY
ALL HAVE IN COMMON.
WE ASK THEM AT THE END OF THE
DAY TO ANONYMOUSLY SHARE ONE
THING THEY WOULD BE WILLING TO
DO DIFFERENTLY MOVING FORWARD.
ONE STUDENT SHARED THAT THEY
WOULD SPEAK UP FOR THOSE WITH NO
VOICE.
ANOTHER STUDENT SHARE THAT THEY
WERE COMMITTED TO STAND UP FOR
WHAT'S RIGHT.
ANOTHER SAID I LEARNED JUST
BECAUSE I'M NOT THE BULLY
DOESN'T MEAN I CAN'T HELP THE
VICTIM.
ANOTHER SHARED I'M COMMITTED TO
MEET A LEADER NOT A FOLLOWER.
OUR GOAL IS TO MAKE INCREMENTAL
CHANGE BY HAVING MORE ON GOING
SUPPORT FOR STUDENTS.
THE USING POWER CONFERENCE IS
JUST THE BEGINNING WE WOULD LIKE
TO CREATE AN AMBASSADOR PROGRAM
WHERE STUDENTS WHO ATTENDED THE
CONFERENCE MEET REGULARLY
THROUGHOUT HIGH SCHOOL TO
BRAINSTORM IDEAS TO IMPLEMENT
THE TOOLS THEY'VE LEARNED.
IN SITUATIONS ARE WITNESSING AT
SCHOOL. 63% OF THE STUDENTS WHO
ATTENDED THE CONFERENCE THIS
YEAR SO THEY WOULD BE INTERESTED
IN STAYING INVOLVED WITH THE
PROGRAM.
ASSOCIATIONS WITH PEERS THAT ARE
POSITIVE INFLUENCE AS WELL AS A
CONNECTION OUR COMMITMENT TO
SCHOOL REDUCE THE LIKELIHOOD OF
BOTH BOWLING AND ADOLESCENT
EATING ABUSE.
THE CONFERENCE PROVIDE STUDENTS
THE SKILLS AND CONFIDENCE TO
SAFELY INTERVENING COMPLEX THEY
WITNESS IT TAKES LONGER TERM
TRAINING TO KEEP IT UP.
SHORT TERM INTERVENTION PROGRAMS
IGNORE THE ONGOING CONDITIONS
THAT NORMALIZED VIOLENCE.
ONGOING BYSTANDER INTERVENTION
PRACTICES.
CAN BE THE FOUNDATION FOR
CHALLENGING SOCIAL NORMS.
STUDENTS CONTINUALLY SUPPORT
EACH OTHER IN INTERVENING WHILE
LEARNING TO BECOME BETTER ALLIES.
THE LOW COST INNOVATIVE
PROGRAMMING THAT WE ARE
CURRENTLY DOING IS MAKING AN
IMPACT.
WITH MORE SUSTAINABLE FUNDING WE
COULD DO EVEN MORE. TO KEEP OUR
PREVENTION PROGRAMMING SECURE WE
SEEK OUT GRANT OPPORTUNITIES BUT
THEY'RE HARD TO COME BY.
AS OF RIGHT NOW OUR PROGRAM IS
FUNDED BY TEMPORARY GRANTS THE
REALITY IS THAT BY THE END OF
NEXT JUNE WHEN ONE OF OUR MAJOR
GRANTS ENDS WE COULD RISK LOSING
50% OF OUR DEDICATED STAFF TIME
TO PREVENTION.
I CATALYSTS WE BELIEVE THAT LOVE
SHOULDN'T HURT WE BELIEVE THAT
EVERYONE DESERVES TO FEEL SAFE
IN THEIR RELATIONSHIPS.
PREVENTION IS THE KEY TO
REDUCING THE INCIDENCE OF
INTIMATE PARTNER VIOLENCE AND
SEXUAL ABUSE.
WE ALL HAVE A ROLE IN KEEPING
OUR COMMUNITY SAFE.
WITHOUT ONGOING SUSTAINABLE
PREVENTION FUNDING THIS CRUCIAL
WORK IS AT RISK OF COMING TO AN
END THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME.
THANK YOU SERRA AND MELODY.
YEAH HI EVERYONE THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR HAVING US HERE THANK
YOU CHAIRMAN RUBIO. FOR PUTTING
THIS TOGETHER HAD SUCH AN
IMPORTANT TOPIC SO I'M MELODY
CRISPO THEN I'M FROM PEACE OVER
VIOLENCE IN LOS ANGELES -- AND
WE ARE A TOOL DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
AND SEXUAL VIOLENCE PROGRAM THAT
SERVES THE COMMUNITY WE WERE
FOUNDED IN NINETEEN SEVENTY ONE
SO WE'RE ONE OF THE OLDEST
ORGANIZATIONS TO BE DOING THIS
KIND OF WORK IN THE NATION --
AND WE'VE BEEN DOING PREVENTION
WORK SPECIFICALLY FOR ALMOST
THIRTY YEARS SO I'VE ALSO BEEN
DOING THIS FOR A REALLY LONG
TIME AND SOMETHING THAT I FEEL.
INCREDIBLY LUCKY. TO BE ABLE TO
SAY IS THAT I RUN A PREVENTION
DEPARTMENT OF EIGHT PEOPLE I
INCLUDING MYSELF SO AS THE
DIRECTOR OF PREVENTION AND
POLICY AT PEACE OVER VIOLENCE --
WE DO A LOT OF WORK -- IN THE
COMMUNITY THAT'S PREVENTION
RELATED -- ALONG WITH THE
SERVICES THAT WE PROVIDE TO
SURVIVORS AND VICTIMS' SO WE DO
EMERGENCY SERVICES INTERVENTION
SERVICES WE ALSO RUN THAT LOS
ANGELES RAPING BATTERING HOTLINE.
AS WELL AS REALLY THE FIRST OF
ITS KIND OF SEXUAL HARASSMENT
HOTLINE OF FOR METRO ARE COUNTY
WIDE -- PUBLIC TRANSPORTATION
SYSTEM.
SO I MEAN I I'M LIKE VERY VERY
PASSIONATE ABOUT PREVENTION AND
THINK IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT AND
PREVENTION IS IMPORTANT NOT ONLY
BECAUSE WE WANT TO PREVENT YOUNG
PEOPLE FROM EXPERIENCING
INTIMATE PARTNER VIOLENCE AND
SEXUAL VIOLENCE IN THEIR
ADULTHOOD BUT ALSO BECAUSE THESE
ARE THINGS THAT ARE IMPACTING
THEM NOW.
AND WE CAN LOOK AT PREVENTION A
COUPLE OF DIFFERENT WAYS WE CAN
LOOK AT IT AS YOU KNOW WHAT CAN
WE DO TO TRY AND PREVENT AN
INCIDENT OF VIOLENCE OCCURRING
AGAIN TO A STUDENT WHO PERHAPS
IS ALREADY DEALT WITH THIS.
BUT ALSO HOW CAN WE DO PRIMARY
PREVENTION AND TRAIN US STOP IT
FROM HAPPENING IN THE FIRST
PLACE -- WE REALLY BELIEVE THAT
DATING VIOLENCE SEXUAL VIOLENCE
TEEN DATING VIOLENCE IS A PUBLIC
HEALTH ISSUE.
I IT DOESN'T JUST AFFECT THE TWO
PEOPLE INVOLVED IT SPILLS OUT
INTO THE COMMUNITY THERE'S
EMERGING RESEARCH THAT THERE'S A
STRONG CONNECTION TO GUN
VIOLENCE -- AND THAT SOME OF THE
FATALITIES OF OF PARTICULARLY
YOUNG WOMEN -- IN DATING
RELATIONSHIPS -- ARE ARE LINKED
TO GUN VIOLENCE AND WE KNOW THAT
THAT'S SOMETHING THAT'S
IMPACTING OUR COMMUNITIES AND
OUR SCHOOLS.
AND ONE THING WE CAN DO TO HELP
ADDRESS THAT ISSUE IS TALK ABOUT
THE PREVENTION OF SEXUAL
VIOLENCE AND DATING VIOLENCE --
AND YOU KNOW IT DATING VIOLENCE
AND SEXUAL VIOLENCE AGAIN JUST
HAVE SO MANY SHARED RISK FACTORS
AND PROTECTIVE FACTORS WITH
OTHER ISSUES THAT WE CARE ABOUT
IN OUR COMMUNITIES.
LIKE GANG VIOLENCE LIKE SUICIDE
LIKE UNWANTED PREGNANCIES THAT
AGAIN IF WE COULD JUST KIND OF
TALK TO YOUNG PEOPLE ABOUT
BUILDING HEALTHY RELATIONSHIPS.
WE COULD HAVE THIS HUGE RIPPLE
EFFECT INTO OTHER ISSUES SO WHAT
I WANTED TO SPEND A LITTLE BIT
OF TIME DOING WAS TO TELL YOU
ABOUT THE KIND OF A RAY OF
DIFFERENT PREVENTION PROGRAMS WE
DO AT PEACE OVER VIOLENCE JUST
TO SHOW.
THAT THERE ARE A LOT OF
DIFFERENT OPTIONS FOR IT AND
THERE ARE A LOT OF WAYS TO GO
ABOUT IT -- SO.
I WANTED TO START WITH SOME OF
OUR SCHOOL BASED PROGRAM JUST
BECAUSE THAT IS A REALLY GREAT
WAY TO WORK WITH YOUTH DIRECTLY
AS WITH THE SCHOOLS SO.
WE WORKED MOST CLOSELY WITH LOS
ANGELES UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT
IT'S THE SECOND LARGEST SCHOOL
DISTRICT IN THE NATION WITH OVER
SEVENTY THOUSAND TEACHERS AND
STAFF HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF
STUDENTS -- AND THE UNFORTUNATE
FACT IS THAT WE CAN'T REACH THEM
ALL BECAUSE OF THAT SIZE AND SO
PART OF WHAT WE'RE REALLY
LOOKING FOR IN TRYING TO
INCREASE FUNDING FOR PREVENTION
IS.
DOING EQUITABLE WORK ACROSS THE
SCHOOLS YOU KNOW IT SHOULDN'T
YOUR PROTECTION AND YOUR SAFETY
SHOULDN'T BE DICTATED BECAUSE
YOU HAPPEN TO BE S. AT A SCHOOL
NEAR PEACE OVER VIOLENCE OR NEAR
ONE OF OUR SISTER AGENCIES AT
SOMETHING.
THAT SHOULD BE GUARANTEED TO
EVERYBODY SO -- WE DO A LOT OF
DIFFERENT THINGS WITH SCHOOLS WE
HAVE A CURRICULUM THAT WE
DEVELOPED AT PEACE OVER VIOLENCE
THAT'S USED ACROSS THE COUNTRY
CALLED IN TOUCH WITH TEENS.
IT'S A COMPREHENSIVE VIOLENCE
PREVENTION CURRICULUM THAT
ADDRESSES BOTH SEXUAL ASSAULT
AND DATING VIOLENCE SO THAT
STUDENTS NOT ONLY LEARN THE
WARNING SIGNS BUT ARE ALSO
LEARNING HOW TO HAVE HEALTHY
RELATIONSHIPS HOW TO DO CONFLICT
RESOLUTION.
HOW TO TALK ABOUT THEIR
BOUNDARIES AND CONSENT HOW TO
UNDERSTAND -- HOW THEY SEE
VIOLENCE AND GENDER IN THE MEDIA
THINGS LIKE THAT SO IT'S REALLY
REALLY FUN?
WE DO IT WITH YOU THAN A LOT OF
DIFFERENT WAYS AND WE PROVIDE
THIS TYPE OF EDUCATION IN MIDDLE
SCHOOLS AND HIGH SCHOOLS AND ON
COLLEGE CAMPUSES AND ACTUALLY --
WE'VE BEEN WORKING WITH SOME OF
THE STUDENTS WHO HAVE BEEN
VICTIMS OF DOCTOR TEN DAHLE AT
USC -- ON SOME OF THESE ISSUES
SO I'M MOST OFTEN WERE IN CLASS
LIKE HEALTH CLASSES -- TO TRY
AND FIT THIS IN A LOT OF THE
SCHOOLS ARE COMING TO US TO HELP
SUPPLEMENT THE CALIFORNIA
HEALTHY YOUTH ACT OF WHICH YOU
KNOW EXPANDED SEX EDUCATION IN
SCHOOLS -- NOT ONLY TO MAKE IT
MANDATORY BUT TO SAY THAT.
STUDENTS HAVE TO LEARN ABOUT
SEXUAL ASSAULT THEY HAVE TO
LEARN ABOUT -- HEALTHY
RELATIONSHIP SKILLS AND A LOT OF
THEM.
THEY DON'T HAVE ALREADY THE
CURRICULUM TO DO THAT AND SO
THEY'VE BEEN CALLING US TO HELP
SUPPLEMENT THAT PART OF THE SEX
THAT EDUCATION -- BUT AGAIN
THERE ARE SOME CHALLENGES LIKE
WITH PASADENA UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT ANOTHER -- DISTRICT
WITHIN OUR SERVICE AREA BECAUSE
OF BUDGET CUTS THAT THAT
DISTRICTS SPECIFICALLY HAS BEEN
SEEING.
THEY'VE CUT HEALTH CLASSES AND
SO IT'S IT'S REALLY ABOUT LIKE
WE HAVE MATH TEACHERS TRYING TO
TEACH SEX ED AND HEALTHY
RELATIONSHIPS NOT TO SAY THAT
THEY DON'T CARE ABOUT IT OR
CAN'T DO IT.
BUT YOU KNOW THERE'S JUST SO
MUCH COMPETITION FOR THIS -- WE
ALSO DO CYCLE EDUCATIONAL GROUPS
WITH YOUNG PEOPLE WHO PERHAPS
ARE AT HIGH RISK OF BEING
VICTIMIZED OR OF VICTIMIZING
OTHERS -- AND A LOT OF TIMES
THOSE GROUPS ARE GENDER SPECIFIC
SO WE ARE WORKING SPECIFICALLY
WITH YOUNG MEN.
SO THAT WE CAN TALK TO THEM
ABOUT WHAT IT MEANS TO BUILD
HEALTHY RELATIONSHIPS ADDRESSING
LIKE TOXIC MASCULINITY THAT.
BEING A MAN DOESN'T HAVE TO MEAN
BEING AGGRESSIVE AND VIOLENT AND
DOMINATING TOWARDS WOMEN AND
ADDRESSING LIKE HETERO
NORMATIVITY IN SOME OF THE
HOMOPHOBIA WITH YOUNG BOYS AND
REALLY TRYING TO CONNECT THEM TO
ADULT MALE MENTORS.
WHO CAN MODEL TO THEM WHAT IT
MEANS TO BE A HEALTHY MAN -- AND
AND HAVE HEALTHY RELATIONSHIPS --
AND WE ALSO DO CAMPAIGNS WITH
THE STUDENTS ACROSS THE SCHOOLS
LIKE DENIM DAY SO LA UNIFIED IN
A LOT OF OUR SCHOOL DISTRICTS --
PROCLAIM DENIM DAY FOR THE
DISTRICTS AND HAVE THEIR
TEACHERS AND STUDENTS WHERE
THESE KINDS OF THINGS -- AND WE
DO EMPOWERMENT SELF DEFENSE FOR
GIRLS ALSO WHICH I THINK IS
REALLY COOL AND WE TRY AND
INJECT A LOT OF PREVENTION
STRATEGIES IN THERE THAT IT'S
NOT JUST ABOUT.
LIKE THE PHYSICAL TECHNIQUES OF
LEARNING HOW TO DEFEND YOURSELF
BUT REALLY TO TALK ABOUT IT'S
OKAY TO BE ASSERTIVE IT'S OKAY
TO SET BOUNDARIES -- AND HOW TO
BE AWARE OF YOUR SURROUNDINGS
THINGS LIKE THAT AND THEN WE
ALSO FOCUS A LOT ON LEADERSHIP
DEVELOPMENT WITH YOUNG PEOPLE SO
WE ALSO HAVE YOUNG PEOPLE DOING
PER GRAMS AT OUR OFFICE -- AND
THROUGHOUT THEIR SCHOOLS TO
BUILD THEIR LEADERSHIP SKILLS
BECAUSE WE KNOW THAT.
THE MORE EMPOWERED THAT YOUNG
PEOPLE FEEL THE MORE OF THESE
LIKE DEVELOPMENTAL AND
LEADERSHIP SKILLS THAT THEY HAVE
THE LESS VULNERABLE THEY ARE TOO
AGAIN PERPETRATE VIOLENCE OR TO
BE VICTIMIZED BY A VIOLENT SO --
WE HAVE A SCHOOL BASED PROGRAM
CALLED STOP CLUBS THAT STANDS
FOR STUDENTS TOGETHER ORGANIZING
PIECE -- AND THAT'S FOR STUDENTS --
ON THEIR SCHOOL CAMPUSES TO
REALLY TAKE THESE ACTIVITIES
INTO THEIR HANDS AND DECIDE WHAT
DO THEY WANT TO DO FOR THEIR
SPECIFIC COMMUNITY BECAUSE NOT
ALL OF LOS ANGELES IS THE SAME
EVERY SCHOOL IS DEALING WITH A
DIFFERENT ISSUE -- AND WE HAD A
LOT OF SIX THAT I ACTUALLY
STARTED OUT IN THE STOP CLUB
PROGRAMS WHEN I WAS A TEENAGER --
AND AND THEY DID A LOT FOR MY
LIFE I ALSO PRO I'M PROVIDING
FOR YOU TODAY.
AN ARTICLE THAT WAS WRITTEN
ABOUT ONE OF OUR STUDENTS IN THE
LOS ANGELES TIMES -- HE'S THE
PRESIDENT OF ONE OF OUR LOCAL
STOP CLUBS -- AND HE GOT INTO
HARVARD -- IT IS THE FIRST IN
HIS FAMILY NOT ONLY TO BE GOING
TO COLLEGE BUT TO GO TO HARVARD --
AND HE TALKS A LOT ABOUT HOW
DOING THESE TYPES OF LEADERSHIP
PROGRAMS TALKING ABOUT OF
VIOLENCE PREVENTION HELPED HIM
TO FEEL LIKE HE COULD BE A
LEADER AND LIKE HARVARD WAS
SOMETHING THAT WAS ATTAINABLE TO
HIM -- WE ALSO HAVE A FIVE WEEK.
INTERNSHIP PROGRAM AN INSTITUTE
THAT WE RUN EVERY SUMMER CALLED
OUR YOUTH OVER VIOLENCE
LEADERSHIP INSTITUTE OF WE
ACCEPT THIRTY STUDENTS INTO THIS
PROGRAM -- SO THAT THEY CAN GET
REALLY IN DEPTH AND TO SEE
THIRTY TEENAGERS SPENDING FIVE
WEEKS OUT OF THEIR SUMMER ALL
DAY JUST TO TALK ABOUT VIOLENCE
PREVENTION IS INCREDIBLY
INSPIRING -- AND WE LIKE TO SAY
THAT YOU KNOW YOUNG PEOPLE ARE
NOT JUST THE LEADERS OF TOMORROW
THEY'RE THE LEADERS OF TODAY --
AND SO THEY WORK ON INTERNSHIPS
PROJECTS THEY DO DIGITAL AND
SOCIAL MEDIA SPOKEN WORD
COMMUNITY ORGANIZING -- SO THAT
THEY CAN REALLY ENGAGE THEIR
PEERS ON THESE KINDS OF ISSUES
AND I'VE ALSO REPORT.
WHY DID TO YOU ANOTHER REPORT
THAT WAS DONE BY THE NATIONAL
RESOURCE CENTER ON DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE THAT TALKS ABOUT THIS
FIVE WEEK PROGRAM THAT WE HAVE
AND HOW IMPACTFUL HOW BENEFICIAL
IT IS IN YOUNG PEOPLE'S LIVES?
BECAUSE WHAT WE'RE REALLY TRYING
TO DO IS AGAIN KIND OF A DRESS
THE SHARED PROTECTIVE FACTORS
THAT HELP US KEEP STUDENTS SAFE
AND WE WANT TO BUILD THINGS LIKE
CONNECTEDNESS TO THEIR COMMUNITY
TO THEIR SCHOOLS TO EACH OTHER.
TO A TRUSTED ADULT BECAUSE THESE
ARE ALL THINGS THAT SAY -- HELP
PREVENT VIOLENCE FROM HAPPENING
IN THE FIRST PLACE AND SO THE
STUDENTS REALLY TAKE ON ISSUES
LIKE GUN VIOLENCE AND
HOMELESSNESS AND THINGS THAT
THEY CARE ABOUT -- THEY DO A DAY
OF THE DEAD AT THE AT THE LOS
MARCOS EVENTS -- WHERE THEY
HONOR PEOPLE WHO HAVE PASSED
BECAUSE OF DOMESTIC VIOLENCE OR
SEXUAL VIOLENCE -- AND AND
THAT'S A WAY TO BRING A CULTURAL
AWARENESS TO THEIR COMMUNITIES
ABOUT THIS SO.
I CAN GO ON AND ON I'M GONNA
STOP IF YOU HAVE ANY QUESTIONS
PLEASE DON'T HESITATE TO LET ME
KNOW.
THANK YOU -- I THINK ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT I CAUGHT -- FROM
THIS AND I HAVE DISCUSSED THIS
ISSUE BEFORE WE TALK ABOUT --
SURVIVORS IN HOW WE HELP
SURVIVORS BUT I THINK THE
PREVENTION -- PORTION OF IT NOT
JUST FOR FEMALES BUT FOR THE BUT
THE BOYS IS ALSO IMPORTANT
BECAUSE WE WANT TO STOP THE THE
CYCLE OF ABUSE -- AND I KNOW
THAT IT'S NOT JUST BY MEN OR
BOYS WHO WHO -- ARE THE
PERPETRATORS RIGHT THEY ARE ALSO
VICTIMS BUT THE MAJORITY ARE MEN
AND IF WE DON'T STOP THE CYCLE
EARLY THEN WE ARE NOT ABLE TO TO
TEACH -- YOU KNOW THE THE
HEALTHY RELATIONSHIPS AFTERWARDS --
BUT THANK YOU I WILL LEAVE -- AT
OPEN FOR THE THE COMMITTEE HAS
ANY QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND AND
ALL THE DIFFERENT WORK THAT
YOU'VE BEEN DOING HAVE YOU
ENCOUNTERED ANY OF THEM THE
CULTURAL DIVIDES WITH THIS IN
THIS CITY AND AND DIFFERENT
GROUPS OF OF SOMETIMES --
HARBORING KEEPING ALL THAT
WITHIN THE COMMUNITY ARE WITHIN
THE HOUSEHOLD AND HOW DO YOU HOW
DO YOU DEAL WITH THAT.
YEAH I CAN ANSWER SO -- YOU KNOW
BEING IN LOS ANGELES WE DO WORK
WITH A VERY DIVERSE -- SET OF
COMMUNITIES WE WORK WITH
INDIGENOUS FOLKS WE WORK WITH --
THE LET NEXT COMMUNITY WITH
DIFFERENT ASIAN AMERICAN
COMMUNITIES MIDDLE EASTERN
COMMUNITIES AND OFTEN.
WE HAVE TO TAKE CULTURE INTO THE
PERSPECTIVE AND SO LIKE I SAID
THAT WAS ONE WAY THAT THE YOUTH
CAME UP WITH THIS IDEA TO DO A
DAY OF THE DEAD EVENT -- BECAUSE
YOU KNOW.
THE OF THE LOS MARCUS'S NOVEMBER
FIRST OCTOBER IS DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE AWARENESS MONTH DO YOU
KIND OF PUT THIS TOGETHER AND
SAID WELL IF WE'RE HONORING
THOSE WHO HAVE PASSED.
LET'S USE THIS TO DRAW ATTENTION
AND THIS IS AN EVENT THAT WE GET
CLOSE TO TWO HUNDRED PEOPLE IN
THE COMMUNITY COMING TO TO COME
TAL TITUS -- TO HONOR THOSE TO
THOSE VICTIMS AND SO WE HAVE TO
TRY AND ADDRESS THINGS LIKE MUCH
SHE MALL OR THE ROLE OF MEN AND
AND THINGS LIKE THAT WE JUST.
I HAD A A STUDENT REPORT LAST
WEEK WHO IS MIDDLE EASTERN
AMERICAN -- AND SHE WAS REALLY
CONCERNED ABOUT HOW HER DAD
WOULD REACT WHEN HE FOUND OUT
THAT SHE HAD BEEN SEXUALLY
ASSAULTED -- AND WAS LIKE
BEGGING US NOT TO TELL HIM
BECAUSE SHE WAS CONCERNED ABOUT
HOW.
THIS MIGHT BE PERCEIVED IN HER
CULTURE AND WHITE SEXUAL SALTS --
MIGHT MEAN TO THEM AND SO IT CAN
BE REALLY DIFFICULT AND I THINK
THAT'S WHY IT'S IMPORTANT -- TO
THINK ABOUT PREVENTION IN
DIFFERENT WAYS AND TO PARTNER
LIKE PEACE OVER VIOLENCE CAN'T
DO EVERYTHING SO WE HAVE OTHER
COMMUNITY OR BECAUSE WE WORK
WITH THAT SPECIFICALLY WORK WITH
DIFFERENT CULTURAL POPULATIONS --
BUT WE NEED SPACES TO ALSO BE
ABLE TO WORK TOGETHER AND TALK
TOGETHER AND SHARE RESOURCES
SHARE INFORMATION SHARE TOOLS
THAT ARE WORKING FOR EACH OF US.
THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS -- AND I
APOLOGIZE I'M RUNNING A LITTLE
BIT LATE HERE IN THIS -- IF IF
YOU ALREADY COVERED SOME OF
THESE THINGS BUT MAYBE IF JUST
BRIEFLY LIKE KIND OF OUTLINE
SOME OF THE THE BIG ISSUES THAT
YOU'RE SEEING A MONK'S USE -- IF
AND AND I SEE WE HAVE A MISSILE
OF AN FROM CATALYST IN IN CHICO
AND MY DISTRICT AND THEY DO
GREAT WORK.
IN THE COMMUNITY THERE.
BUT YES MAYBE JUST.
REALLY BRIEFLY IF IF YOU MAYBE
HAVE ALREADY COVERED A LOT OF
THIS STUFF.
I JUST OUTLINED SOME OF THE BIG
THINGS THAT YEARS YOU GUYS ARE
SEEN.
I YEAH I CAN GET STARTED THEM.
I THINK THE YOUNG PEOPLE I'LL A
BIG FEAR THAT WE SEE IS FEAR OF
REPORTING -- BECAUSE THEY DON'T
WANT TO GET THEMSELVES IN
TROUBLE THEY DON'T GET THEIR
PARTNERS IN TROUBLE ESPECIALLY
IF IT'S A YOUNG PERSON WHO'S
DATING SOMEONE OVER THE AGE OF
EIGHTEEN THERE'S A LOT OF FEAR
THERE ABOUT GETTING THEIR
PARTNER IN TROUBLE -- SO THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT WE TRY TO WORK
WITH AND WE DO ALSO DO A GROUP
WITH JUVENILE HALL EVERY SINGLE
WEEK -- WHICH IS A REALLY GREAT
OPPORTUNITY TO WORK WITH PEOPLE --
YOUNG PEOPLE WHO ARE AT THE
HIGHEST RISK -- AND WE KNOW THAT
THE YEAH THE INCARCERATED YOUTH
ARE ACTUALLY USE THAT MOST
LIKELY HAVE BEEN VICTIMIZED
THEMSELVES FROM VARIOUS FORMS OF
ABUSE WE TALK ABOUT ACES.
THEY'RE PRETTY HIGH UP THERE ON
THE SCALE SO WE WE WORK WITH
THEM -- TO EMPOWER THEM TO BE
ABLE TO MAKE HEALTHY CHOICES --
TO BUILD A RELATIONSHIP
COMMUNICATION SKILLS THINGS THAT
MAYBE THEY'VE NEVER HAD ACCESS
TO BEFORE -- SO HELPING THEM
WITH THAT -- ASSEMBLY MEMBER
RAMOS MENTIONED THE CULTURAL
PIECE AS WELL AND WE DO HAVE A
BI LINGUAL COMMUNICATOR ON STAFF
WHO SPECIFICALLY WORKS OF THE
LOT NEXT COMMUNITY -- AND TRIES
TO MAKE OUR CONTENT RELEVANT FOR
THAT COMMUNITY AS WELL BECAUSE
THERE IS ABSOLUTELY THE CONCERN
OF I'M LIKE AIRING YOUR DIRTY
LAUNDRY.
I'M HAVING A PRIVATE ISSUE
BECOME PUBLIC AND AND ALSO
DEFINITELY THE RELIGIOUS
COMPONENT HAVE I'M WANTING TO
STAY WITH YOUR PARTNER NOT
WANTING TO DIVORCE AND I'M
WANTING. TO TO FOLLOW AM FOLLOW
THAT THOSE WAYS OF THINKING AND
SO WE WANT TO BE ABLE TO WORK
WITH THE COMMUNITY AND SO I'M
TELLING THEM WHAT TO DO KIND OF
WORKING WITH.
THEM -- WHAT'S BEST FOR THEM AS
WELL SO THERE'S A COUPLE THINGS
THAT COME TO MIND FOR ME.
THANKS YEAH I AGREE I AGREE WITH
ALL OF THOSE THINGS THAT YOU
SHARED AND I THINK THAT THE
YOUTH THAT WE WORK WITH AND
YOUTH CULTURE IN GENERAL RIGHT
NOW AT LEAST IN MY SOMEWHAT
ISOLATED COMMUNITY OF MARIPOSA --
THEY ARE VERY ENGAGED IN THEIR
LIVES AND IN THE WORLD THE
REALLY WELL INFORMED ABOUT
ISSUES AND I THINK -- TECHNOLOGY
HAS A LOT TO DO THAT -- I WOULD
SAY THAT YOUNG PEOPLE AND ADULTS --
TOO STILL ARE LEARNING ABOUT HOW
TO HAVE HEALTHY RELATIONSHIPS
AND WHAT IS HEALTHY AND WHAT
ISN'T AND OFTENTIMES CERTAIN
BEHAVIORS ARE NORMALIZED LIKE
CONTROLLING BEHAVIORS OR EXTREME
JEALOUSY OR SO BEING ABLE. TO TO
DIFFERENTIATE BETWEEN
CONTROLLING AND CARING BEHAVIOR
IS A DIFFICULT THING FOR US ALL
TO NAVIGATE AND SO THE MORE
OPPORTUNITY WE HAVE TO TALK
ABOUT THAT AND TO SEE EXAMPLES
OF HEALTHY A RESPECTFUL
RELATIONSHIPS VERSES
RELATIONSHIPS THAT ARE MAYBE NOT
BASED ON THE QUALITY.
IS GREAT FOR YOUNG PEOPLE AND
FOR ALL OF US AT THE SAME TIME.
AND SO DEVELOPING OF LANGUAGE TO
DISCUSS THESE TOPICS THAT TAKES
INTO ACCOUNT EVERYONE'S
DIFFERENT EXPERIENCES AND
CULTURES AND RACE AND SEX AND
GENDER AND ALL THAT IT'S A LOT
TO BREAK DOWN AND SO WE NEED TO
BE ABLE TO DO THAT IN A IN A
HIGH QUALITY WAY I'M
[inaudible]
SO.
THAT'S WHAT COMES TO MIND THANKS
FOR YOUR QUESTION.
I WANTED TO SAY TO SPECIFIC
THINGS WERE SEEING IN LOS
ANGELES AT LEAST -- ONE IS.
WE HAVE A HIGH LEVEL OF
UNACCOMPANIED MINORS IN LOS
ANGELES SO YOUNG PEOPLE WHO HAVE
COME FROM CENTRAL AND NORTHERN
I'M -- AMERICA.
AND WHO ARE UNFAMILIAR WITH OUR
ALLIES -- AND SO YOU MIGHT HAVE
STUDENTS WHO ARE USING ON
HEALTHY BEHAVIORS BECAUSE
PERHAPS THAT'S WHAT THEY
EXPERIENCE FROM THEIR HOME
COUNTRY OR THERE'S DIFFERENT
CULTURE AND AND ACCEPTED
BEHAVIORS IN THEIR HOME COUNTRY
AND AND HELPING TO PROVIDE THEM
WITH EDUCATION ON THINGS LIKE
CONSENT AND WHAT'S OKAY AND NOT.
OKAY -- NOW THAT YOU'RE IN THIS
COUNTRY AND SO EDUCATING THEM
ABOUT -- THE LAWS HERE IN ABOUT
SAFETY AND THINGS LIKE THAT
ANOTHER THING WE'VE SEEN IS A
REALLY BIG INCREASE IN REQUESTS
FROM TEACHERS ON A BECAUSE WE
PROVIDE TRAINING FOR TEACHERS AS
WELL.
TRAINING ON ADDRESSING SEXUAL
HARASSMENT WE'VE SEEN A MARKET
UP TICK IN SEXUAL HARASSMENT
PARTICULARLY AT THE MIDDLE
SCHOOL LEVEL -- THAT THE
TEACHERS JUST HAVE A REALLY HARD
TIME -- KNOWING HOW TO PREVENT
OR OR TALK ABOUT.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER QUESTIONS.
WELL THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND I'M
INTERESTED IN GETTING THE
INFORMATION ON ON YOUR PROGRAMS --
I AM YOU KNOW -- WANT.
TO BRING SOME OF THOSE PROGRAMS
TO MY COMMUNITIES AS WELL AND SO
IF ANYBODY'S INTERESTED IF YOU
CAN PROVIDE SOME OF THAT
INFORMATION AND THE MODEL
PROGRAMS BECAUSE I I THINK ALL
THREE OF THEM.
ARE EXCELLENT AND I I KNOW THAT
THEIR SPECIFIC TO YOUR AREAS BUT
I SEE THE VALUE IN THOSE AND I
THINK THAT WE CAN YOU KNOW
SOMEHOW I LEASE BRING THEM. TO
OUR COMMUNITIES AS VIRAL SITE
WHICH WOULD APPRECIATE IF YOU
CAN PROVIDE THAT AND YOU KNOW
SPREADING AROUND THE PROGRAMS
THAT I'M LISTENING. TO THAT YOU
HAVE ARE AMAZING AND I DIDN'T
REALIZE THAT YOU WERE ALL ENGAGE
AND THAT'S WHY IT'S IMPORTANT TO
HAVE THESE KINDS OF OF
CONVERSATIONS SO IF ANYBODY ELSE
THAT IS LISTENING OR ANYBODY IN
THE AUDIENCE WANTS TO MODEL SOME
OF THOSE PROGRAMS YOU'VE ALREADY.
DONE IT YOU'RE ALREADY DOING IT
AND I'M ALSO INTERESTED IN HOW
YOU GOT THOSE GRANTS I'M STILL
STUCK ON THE GRANT.
WILL BECAUSE THE SEAT IT NEVER
OCCURRED TO ME THAT THE CDC
WOULD PROVIDE GRANTS FOR FOR FOR
PROGRAMS LIKE THIS AND NOW THAT
WE KNOW -- WE THAT IT DOESN'T
HAVE TO BE SPECIFICALLY
CALIFORNIA FUNDED IT CAN ALSO BE
IN PARTNERSHIP WITH THE CDC I
THINK THAT'S A VALUE TO OUR
COMMUNITIES BECAUSE I'M PROBABLY
THINKING ALL MORE MONEY MORE
MONEY MORE MONEY THAT WE YOU
KNOW THE THE THOSE.
RESOURCES ARE LIMITED BUT IF WE
CAN GET SOME OF THAT FUNDING
FROM THE CDC SOME ALL THE VERY
INTERESTED IN FINDING OUT WHAT
THE BUT THE THE GRANT IS AND HOW
WE CAN.
HELP OTHER -- COMMUNITIES OBTAIN
THOSE THOSE GRANT CELL THANK YOU
VERY MUCH OUR LADY'S FOR YOUR
PRESENTATION IF WE CAN MOVE ON
TO THE NEXT PANEL WHICH WAS
ACTUALLY A GOOD I THINK WE ARE
NEXT -- TOPIC IT'S CULTURALLY
SPECIFIC PREVENTION WORK -- AND
IF WE CAN HAVE CONNIE CHUNG JOE --
ALSO -- DANIEL MARTINEZ -- COME
UP TO THE DIES PLEASE.
WELCOME SO CONNIE WOULD YOU LIKE
TO START YES AND YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR HAVING
ME -- FOR THE PAST TEN YEARS
I'VE SERVED AS THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF KOREAN AMERICAN
FAMILY SERVICES ARE QUE PFAM
WHERE THIRTY SIX YEAR OLD
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATION IN
LOS ANGELES.
ADDRESSING THE NEEDS OF
STRUGGLING CREAN AMERICAN
FAMILIES ARE FORTY ONE STAFF
WORK WITH OVER SEVEN THOUSAND
CLIENTS A YEAR SERVING WITH
SERVICES RANGING FROM DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE TO MENTAL HEALTH TO
FOSTER CARE AND OTHER FAMILY
SUPPORT. FOR THE PAST EIGHT
YEARS IN LARGE PART DUE FUNDING
FROM BLUE SHIELD FOUNDATION K.
FAMILIES INVESTED OVER A MILLION
DOLLARS IN TRAINING AND
PARTNERING WITH CREE AND FAITH
LEADERS. TO DATE WE'VE TRAINED
OVER A THOUSAND KOREAN CLERGY ON
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE TWO FORTY OUR
TRAININGS SEMINARY CLASSES TO
DAY RETREATS ALL THE CONFERENCES
AND THER WORKSHOPS.
LIKE MANY IMMIGRANT COMMUNITIES
AND COMMUNITIES OF COLOR FAITH
BASED INSTITUTIONS ARE CRITICAL
BECAUSE THAT'S WHERE THE
COMMUNITY COMES TOGETHER TO
SOCIALIZE EXCHANGE INFORMATION.
PASSED ON CULTURAL PRACTICES TO
THEIR CHILDREN AND TO BREAK BACK
AND TO BREAK BREAD OR IN OUR
CASE WE SHARE KIMCHI. 7280% OF
KOREAN IMMIGRANTS ATTEND CHURCH
AND THAT'S WHERE THE FAMILY GOES
WHEN THERE'S A CRISIS IT'S A
PERSON THAT'S THEIR PASTOR OR
THE PASTOR'S WIFE THAT THEY WANT
TO SPEAK.
TO THEY DO NOT COME FIRST TO A
PROFESSIONAL D. V. AGENCY.
WHAT'S INTERESTING IS HOW WE
HEAR SIMILAR STORIES ACROSS SO
MANY CULTURAL GROUPS ABOUT THE
ROLE FAITH LEADERS PLAY IN
ADDRESSING DOMESTIC VIOLENCE.
CASE THEM AS PART OF THE
CULTURALLY RESPONSIVE DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE NETWORK WHICH IS A
GROUP OF SEVENTEEN CULTURALLY
SPECIFIC AGENCIES ACROSS THE
STATE FUNDED BY BLUE SHIELD.
THAT FOCUSES ON ADDRESSING TV IN
OUR RESPECTIVE UNDERSERVED
COMMUNITIES WITH WE SHARE WITH
EACH OTHER OUR LESSONS LEARNED
IN OUR BEST PRACTICES AND WHAT'S
SURPRISING IS DESPITE HOW
DIFFERENT OUR COMMUNITIES ARE.
THERE ARE SIMILARITIES IN THE
WAY WE ARE SERVING ARE
VULNERABLE COMMUNITIES SO
WHETHER YOU'RE IN CENTRAL VALLEY
WORKING WITH AMONG SHAMANS OR IN
OAKLAND WORKING WITH BLACK
CHURCHES.
ARE BASICALLY ANYWHERE IN
CALIFORNIA WORKING WITH LATINO
PRIEST.
FAITH LEADERS ARE UNIQUELY
POSITIONED TO INFLUENCE CULTURAL
NORMS AND SERVE AS FIRST
RESPONDERS TO FAMILIES IN CRISIS.
SO THERE'S A LOT OF TRUST
BUILDING THAT NEEDS TO HAPPEN
WHEN YOU WORK WITH FAITH LEADERS.
CREE INJURE CHURCHES IN GENERAL
WE HOLD THE HOLD.
CONSERVATIVE CHRISTIAN VALUES
AND FEEL THEIR ROLE IS TO PUT
THE FAMILY FIRST WHEREAS IN THE
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE FIELD WHERE
PROGRESSIVE FEMINIST BASED
MOVEMENT WAY PUT THE SURVIVOR AT
THE CENTER.
SO CAN BE CHALLENGING REACHING
ACROSS THE AISLE AT TIMES WHEN
VALUES AND PERSPECTIVES SEEMS SO
DISPARATE.
SOMETHING TRANSFORMATIONAL
HAPPENS WHEN YOU BRING A GROUP
OF FAITH LEADERS TOGETHER AND
LET THEM TALK TOGETHER ABOUT
WITH TV LOOKS LIKE IN THEIR
COMMUNITIES.
SO WHEN WE HAVE A TWO DAY
RETREAT AND FEMALE FAITH LEADERS
CHOOSE TO SET UP TILL TWO AM IN
THE MORNING SO THEY CAN CONTINUE
SHARING STORIES.
SOMETHING MAGICAL HAPPENS IN
THAT MOMENT BECAUSE WHAT THEY'RE
DOING IS THEY'RE TAKING THE DB
EDUCATION THAT THEY'VE LEARNED
FROM EARLIER IN THAT DAY.
AND THEY'RE TURNING IT INTO A
PERSONAL REFLECTION.
ON HOW THEY OR THOSE AROUND THEM
HAVE BEEN IMPACTED BY TV.
AND TV SHOULD BE A PERSONAL
DISCUSSION BECAUSE EVERYONE HAS
BEEN IMPACTED BY IT.
WHEN YOU CONSIDER THAT ONE IN
THREE WOMEN EXPERIENCE TV IN HER
LIFETIME HOW CAN IT NOT BE
SOMETHING PERSONAL TO ALL OF US?
STATISTICALLY SPEAKING UNLESS
YOU LIVE ALONE IN A DESERTED
ISLAND WE ARE ALL CONNECTED TO
SOMEONE WHO HAS EXPERIENCE TV
WHETHER IT'S A RELATIVE OR
FRIEND A COLLEAGUE OF CONGRESS
OR OUR AND THAT'S THE VALUE OF
PREVENTION WORK IT TAKES WE SEE.
IT TAKES WHAT SEEMS LIKE AN
ABSTRACT SOCIETAL ILL AND IT
TURNS IT INTO SOMETHING DEEPLY
PERSONAL THAT EVERYONE CAN
RELATE TO AND WANT TO FIX.
LAST YEAR WHEN I TESTIFIED I
SHARED WITH SOME OF YOU MY OWN
PERSONAL STORY ABOUT COMING FROM
A FAMILY WITH THREE GENERATIONS
OF DOMESTIC VIOLENCE.
HOW MY MOTHER GREW UP WITH AN
ABUSIVE FATHER?
AND ONE DAY WHEN SHE WAS A
TEENAGER.
SHE WENT TO HER ROOM.
AND SHE SLIT HER WRISTS.
AND SHE WROTE A MESSAGE TO HER
FATHER WITH HER OWN BLOOD.
AND SHE SAID THAT IF SHE EVER
SAW MY GRANDFATHER HIT MY
GRANDMOTHER AGAIN SHE WOULD KILL
HERSELF.
I SHARED HOW THEIR FAMILY
MEMBERS AROUND ME WHO EXPERIENCE
TV.
AND HOW I WORRY THAT TV MIGHT
PASS ALONG TO THE FOURTH
GENERATION OF MY CHILDREN AND MY
NIECES AND NEPHEWS.
WHAT I DIDN'T SHARE WAS THAT
WHEN I STARTED AT DICK AT CAPE
DAM IT NEVER OCCURRED TO ME THAT
TV WAS A PERSONAL ISSUE?
MY PARENTS WERE NOT ABUSIVE
TOWARDS IT THEN IT TOWARDS EACH
OTHER I HAD NEVER BEEN AN
ABUSIVE RELATIONSHIP.
THEREFORE IT SEEMS LIKE AN
ABSTRACT PROBLEM.
IT WAS ONLY AFTER I STARTED
WORKING AT QUE PFAM DID I START
TO REALIZE THAT MY FAMILY'S
HISTORY AND EXPERIENCE WITH TV
WAS OF COURSE PERSONAL.
AND EVEN IF I NEVER WITNESSED
ABUSE MYSELF KNOWING THAT MY
GRANDFATHER'S ABUSE HAS LEFT A
LEGACY THAT'S BEEN PASSED FROM
GENERATION TO GENERATION DOWN
OUR FAMILY TREE.
NOW MAKES IT A DEEPLY PERSONAL
ISSUE.
EVERYONE OF THE FAITH LEADERS WE
TRAIN AT KEITH THEM KNOW SOMEONE
WHO HAS BEEN A VICTIM OR
PERPETRATOR OF DOMESTIC VIOLENCE.
ALTHOUGH MOST DO NOT REAL
RECOGNIZE THAT BEFORE THEY COME
TO OUR TRAINING.
BUT THEN WE START TO TALK ABOUT
KOREAN COMMUNITIES.
AND HOW THE INTERGENERATIONAL
CYCLE OF VIOLENCE HAS A LONG
TERM DEVASTATING IMPACT ON OUR
CHILDREN.
WHO GO ON TO REPEAT WHAT THEY
SAW WITH THEIR PARENTS?
AND THAT'S WHEN OUR FAITH LEADER
START TO THINK ABOUTTHEIR OWN
FAMILIES AND THEIR OWN
CHILDHOODS AND THEIR OWN FRIENDS
AND THEIR CONGREGANTS AND THEY
REALIZE THAT THEY WERE PATTERNS
AND SIGNS OF ABUSE EVERYWHERE
AROUND THEM.
AFTER THE TRAININGS WE SEE AN
INCREASE IN REFERRALS BECAUSE
THE FAITH LEADERS KNOW NOW HOW
TO IDENTIFY DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
BEYOND A BLACK GUY OR HOSPITAL
VISITS.
AND THEY KNOW HOW TO APPROACH
THE SUBJECT OF GETTING SOMEONE
TO A TV AGENCY FOR HELP.
RATHER THAN LIMITING THEIR
INTERVENTION TO PRAYER ALONE.
LAST YEAR KPM SERVED A HUNDRED
CREE AND DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
SURVIVORS THIS IS THE HIGHEST
NUMBER WE HAVE EVER SERVED AND A
33% INCREASE FROM PAST YEARS.
MANYOF THOSE REFERRALS CAME TO
US THROUGH THE FAITH LEADERS WHO
HAD RECEIVED OUR TRAINING. FOR
MORE THAN JUST THE UP TAKEN
REFERRALS THERE'S A SLOWER
SUDLER BUT EVEN MORE PROFOUND
CHANGE THAT'S OCCURRING THROUGH
THESE TRAININGS.
BECAUSE AS FAITH LEADERS CHANGE
THE WAY THEY THINK ABOUT THE
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE THEY START
TALKING AND PREACHING ABOUT HOW
EVIL DOMESTIC VIOLENCE IS.
HOW IT DESTROYS OUR FAMILIES AND
HOW THERE IS NO PLACE FOR IT IN
A CHRISTIAN FAMILY?
WHEREAS THE STARTED OFF
BELIEVING THAT TV MUST BE IN
TOUR FOR THE SAKE OF PROTECTING
A FAMILY ONCE THEY GET TRAINED
THEY REALIZE SAID TV MUST BE
STOPPED FOR THE SAKE OF THE
FAMILY.
THIS CHANGE MENTALITIES BEING
SPREAD BY ARGUABLY THE MOST
INFLUENCE INFLUENTIAL LEADERS OF
OUR CLEAN AMERICAN COMMUNITY.
AND I SEE ARGUABLY BECAUSE NOW
WE HAVE BTS THAT'S TAKING OVER
THE WORLD.
BECAUSE NO MATTER HOW MANY
CRISIS CALLS KVM ANSWERS HOW
MANY SAFETY PLANS WE CREATE OR
HOW MANY RESTRAINING ORDERS WE
FILE.
THOSE WILL NOT LEAD OUR
COMMUNITY TO END DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE.
IT'S THE CHANGE IN ATTITUDE
TOWARDS DOMESTIC VIOLENCE WITH
ART THOUSAND TRAINED FAITH
LEADERS ARE SPREADING.
THAT IS WHAT WILL EVENTUALLY
LEAD TO THE END OF TV IN OUR
COMMUNITY.
THAT IS WHY AS A MEMBER OF THE
CULTURALLY RESPONSIVE DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE NETWORK AND AS A PART
OF THE CALIFORNIA PARTNERSHIP TO
END DOMESTIC VIOLENCE -- WE A WE
URGE THE STATE TO CONSIDER HOW
TO FIND ADDITIONAL DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE PREVENTION WORK.
THAT WILL ALLOW NEW AND
INNOVATIVE PROGRAMS THAT WILL
REACH UNDERSERVED CULTURALLY
SPECIFIC COMMUNITIES LIKE OURS.
WHO HAD BEEN TRADITIONALLYSO
HARD TO REACH IN THE STATE?
THANK YOU I'M.
IT SOUNDS LIKE -- IT'S NOT JUST
A KOREAN AMERICAN -- ISSUE I
THINK THAT IF WE CAN TAKE SOME
OF THAT THAT INFORMATION AND
BRING IT TO ALL OF OUR LATINO
CHURCHES AND YOU KNOW ALL THE
OTHER CHURCHES I THINK THAT'S
THE THE TYPE OF TRAINING THAT I
THAT I THINK WE ALL NEED AND SO
I THINK YOU -- FOR FOR FOR
PRESENTING AND IF THERE'S ANY
QUESTIONS FROM THE PANEL OR ANY
COMMENTS.
I'M SORRY FROM THE COMMITTEE IS.
DOES IS SAY I MEAN THAT WAS VERY
POWERFUL STORE THAT YOU SHARED --
AND HOW THAT IS IS WORKING WITH
AND ARE WORKING IN AND THROUGH
OUR FAITH COMMUNITIES.
YOU KNOW TO RECOGNIZE THIS AS AN
ISSUE AND I AM SEEN THAT MORE
MORE I I I I SEE IN THE FAITH
COMMUNITIES.
MY BROTHER IN LAW'S ACTUALLY
PASTOR -- DOWN IN -- IN THE
POWER WAY AREA -- AND THEY
RECENTLY HELD A CONFERENCE WHERE.
THEY HAD RACHEL -- DEN HOLLANDER
COME AND SPEAK AND TALK ABOUT
YOU KNOW HER.
HER GROWING UP IN THE CHURCH AND
YOU KNOW WHEN SHE HAD FIRST
TALKED ABOUT THIS PEOPLE NOT --
NOT BELIEVING HER IGHT -- AND
HOW BUT HOW.
THROUGH HER FAITH COMMUNITY.
YOU KNOW THAT THAT BEGAN TO
CHANGE.
AND ULTIMATELY LED TO HER BEING
THE FIRST TO COME FORWARD
AGAINST LARRY NASSER -- AND AND
EVERYTHING THAT TRANSPIRED --
THEREAFTER -- BUT HOW OUR FAITH
COMMUNITIES AS YOU WERE TALKING
ABOUT CAN MAYBE. ONE THERE'S A
LOT OF GREAT THINGS WE LEARN
FROM OUR FAITH COMMITTEES HAVING
LOVING COMMITTED RELATIONSHIPS
YOU KNOW THOSE ARE OBVIOUSLY
VERY HEALTHY THINGS -- BUT AS
SOMEONE ELSE -- MENTION MAYBE AT
TIMES LIKE SAY HEY NOT WE DON'T
WANT AREA AIR DIRTY LAUNDRY.
THESE -- KIND OF NOT WANTING TO
TALK ABOUT MANY THINGS THAT ARE
NOT GOING SO WELL -- FOR FEAR OF
OF SOME KIND OF EFFECT A
REPUTATION OR AND SO.
YOU KNOW THERE'S SOME GREAT WORK
I THINK IS GOING ON IN OUR
CHURCHES AND OUR FAITH
COMMUNITIES WHERE IT'S SAYING
HEY LET'S.
LET'S BE REAL ABOUT THINGS THAT
ARE HAPPENING AND LETS.
YOU KNOW EMPOWER BUYER FACE WORK
THROUGH THOSE THINGS AND AND
ACTUALLY BRING ABOUT.
HEALING AND RECONCILIATION --
AND AND AND CALLING OUT THESE
THINGS THAT ARE GOING ON RIGHT
AND NOT BEING AFRAID TO CALL
THEM OUT -- THAT THAT'S REALLY
PART OF THAT'S REALLY PART OF OF
OUR FAITH RIGHT -- IT IS FAITH
IN ACTION -- AND SO -- ANYWAYS I
JUST I WAS REALLY STRUCK BY THAT
YOUR YOUR PRESENTATION AND YOU
KNOW THANK YOU FOR THE GOOD WORK
THEY ARE DOING AND CERTAINLY
WHAT I THINK THIS IS.
SOMETHING WE'RE SEEING IN A LOT
OF DIFFERENT AREAS AND AND
HOPEFULLY WILL CONTINUE TO
EXPAND [inaudible]
ANYONE ELSE.
THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE AND I
THINK -- YOU KNOW.
EVERY TIME.
A SURVIVOR A CHILD TO SURVIVE
TELL THEIR STORY I THINK IT'S
REALLY IMPORTANT TO BRING IT OUT
OF THE DARKNESS I THINK YOU FOR
SHARING YOUR MOM STORAGE HERE
TODAY -- AND I THINK THAT IT'S
SUCH A GREAT MODEL THAT YOU GUYS
ARE USING LIKE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GALLAGHER SPOKE ABOUT USING
TRUSTED COMMUNITIES RIGHT I MEAN
THE FAITH BASED COMMUNITIES OF
THE COMMUNITIES WE TRUST WHERE
WE FEEL SAFE.
RIGHT IN TRAINING THOSE THAT THE
COMMUNITY ALREADY TRUST TO BE
OUR PARTNERS IN HELPING IDENTIFY
THIS AND BREAK THE CYCLE AS YOU
DESCRIBED I THINK IS SO CRUCIAL.
AND ONE OF THE THINGS I WOULD
URGE US TO THINK ABOUT IS --
EXPANDING HIS WORK IN FAITH
BASED COMMUNITIES AS THE CHAIR
MENTIONED BUT ALSO THINKING WHAT
ARE THE OTHER TRUSTED
COMMUNITIES THAT WE CAN TAKE
THIS INTO OUT YOU KNOW CONTINUE
TO FAITH BASED WORK BUT ALSO.
LOOK AT WHERE TO WE HAVE TRUSTED
SOURCES THAT WE CAN TRAIN PEOPLE
SO THAT IT'S NOT HAVING TO GO
SOMEWHERE NEW. TO GET STARTED IN
THE PROCESS OF HEALING AND
BREAKING THE CYCLE AND SO THANK
YOU FOR YOUR WORK AND I HOPE WE
CAN EXPAND IT [inaudible]
WITH A WITH THE TREES.
IT WAS IT WAS INCREDIBLY
POWERFUL FOR ME TO HEAR -- TO
HEAR YOUR STORY AND HEAR ABOUT
THE WORK THAT YOU'RE DOING I AM
SO IN WHEN I WAS GROWING AT IN A
FAITH BASED COMMUNITY
UNFORTUNATELY.
YOU KNOW THAT.
THE THE PASTOR WHO SHOULD HAVE
BEEN OUR TRUSTED ADVISER AND
SHOULD HAVE BEEN THE ONE TO
INTERVENE.
YOU KNOW WHEN WHEN WE WENT AND
TALKED TO HIM ABOUT THE FACT
THAT MY MOTHER WAS BEING ABUSED
IN MY STEP BROTHER IS BEING
ABUSED.
HE SAID SAID TO ME AS A TWELVE
YEAR OLD HE SAID WELL THE MAN IS
THE HEAD OF THE HOUSEHOLD AND
HE'S THE ONE WHO WHO NEEDS TO
MAKE DECISIONS ABOUT WHAT'S
RIGHT FOR YOUR FAMILY AND THAT
WAY IS.
THAT WAS WRONG NOT IN AT NIGHT I
THINK IN ANY OF OUR FAITH
TRADITIONS.
YOU KNOW WHAT OUR FAITH IS ABOUT
AND I'M YOU KNOW WHAT FAMILY IS
ABOUT WHAT SUPPORT IS ABOUT SO.
IT'S REALLY ENCOURAGING TO ME TO
HEAR.
I THINK THAT WE'RE MAKING GOOD
PROGRESS AND YOUR CLEARLY THE
ROLE THAT FAITH LEADERS PLAY AND
HELPING ADDRESS THIS IS
INCREDIBLY POWERFUL SO.
I'M VERY ENCOURAGED AND AS YOU
SAID.
VERY INTERESTED IN THINKING
ABOUT HOW CAN WE TAKE SOME OF
THE BEST PRACTICES THAT HAVE
WORKED IN THE COMMUNITIES ARE
WORKING WITH.
AN AMPLIFIED THAT -- ACROSS OUR
COMMUNITIES AND ACROSS THE STATE.
THANK YOU MISTER GOOD.
DOES WAS A THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR YOUR COURAGE -- I WORK WITH
THE FAITH BASED COMMUNITIES
BECAUSE I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT
BECAUSE AGAIN -- THE FAITH BASED
COMMUNITY STANDS AS A LEADER --
IN OUR COMMUNITIES AND SHOULD
CERTAINLY BE -- ONE TRUSTED BUT
ALSO TALK ABOUT YOU KNOW THE
GENERATIONAL CURSES -- AND
BREAKING THE CURSE -- AND IS IS
GENERATIONAL BECAUSE OF YOU KNOW
SOMEONE SEE THAT YOU KNOW
DADDY'S BEATING MOMMY AND THEN
WHEN HE GROWS UP HE THINKS
THAT'S THE RIGHT THING TO DO IS
THE WRONG THING TO DO.
LOVE IS NOT SUPPOSED TO HURT.
LET ME SAY THAT AGAIN LOVE IS
NOT SUPPOSED TO HURT RIGHT AND
SO WE HAVE TO START REALLY --
USING MY COLLEAGUES -- COMMENTS
THAT GOING TO THE FAITH BASED
LEADER AND NOT GETTING THE
SUPPORT.
IS ANOTHER EXAMPLE WHY WE NEED --
TO TRAIN OUR FAITH BASED LEADERS
IN THIS PARTICULAR AREA SO WE
CAN BEGIN TO TEAR DOWN THE WALLS --
AND ALSO BREAK THE CURSES THAT
CREEPS INTO OUR HOMES AND SO I
WANT TO ENGAGE ENCOURAGE YOU --
ONE LADY SAID I USED TO USE IT
USE THE PHRASE -- DV SHE SAID
DON'T DO THAT.
DON'T DON'T USE THAT TV SAID OUT
LOUD TO EVERYBODY KNOW WHAT D.
V. MEANS DOMESTIC VIOLENCE.
AND SAID OFTEN -- AS YOU
POSSIBLY CAN SO WHEN SOMEONE
HEAR YOU SAYING NOT D. V. BUT
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE THAT COULD BE
THE PERPETRATOR THAT COULD BE
THE INDIVIDUAL OR VICTIM HEARING
THE WORDS.
AND ALSO SOMETHING CAN CHANGE IN
TERMS OF SEEKING HELP OR STOP
DOING WHAT THEY'RE DOING AND SO
WE WANT ENCOURAGE PEOPLE TO USE
THE WORD -- I'LL USE THEM AND IN
A VERY LOUD VOICE -- SO THEY CAN
RESIGNATION -- NOW IN THE
CHAMBERS BUT ALSO IN THE HALLS
AS WELL AS WE WOULD ENCOURAGE
YOU CONTINUE ON SPREADING THE
WORD AND THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
YOUR TESTIMONY.
THANK YOU THANK YOU MISTER MOST
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND YOU
ALLUDED TO OF GENERATIONS OF OF
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE -- YOUR
GRANDMOTHER AND AND SOME OF
THOSE HOW DID HOW DO YOU THEN
WORK WITHIN THE THE CULTURAL
ASPECT TO START TO GET AWAY FROM.
THOSE THINGS I I KNOW THAT IN
SOME CULTURES IT'S A VERY RUDE --
ME IN AND AND HOW THINGS ARE ARE
BEING PERPETRATED BASED ON WHAT
THEY'VE SEEN PRIOR AND FEEL THAT
IS PART OF THE THE THE CULTURAL
ASPECT OF IT.
SO HOW DO YOU DIVE INTO THAT AND
START TO CHANGE THAT FROM THE
ROOT OF THE PROBLEM FROM THE
BEGINNING RIGHT AND AND I I
AGREE WITH THAT I AND I'VE
SPOKEN TO SOME OF MY LATINO
COUNTERPARTS IN OTHER ADVOCATES
SAY TALK ABOUT THEM THAT YOU
SMALL IN THE COMMUNITY.
AND THE CULTURE AS WELL -- SO
CREAM CULTURE BEING THAT IS A
CONFUCIAN PATRIARCHAL THE OTHER
BASED SOCIETY THERE IS THIS
HISTORY OF IT BEING VERY MALE
DOMINATED AND THE FATHER HAS A
RULE.
THE WOMAN'S ROLE WAS
TRADITIONALLY TO OBEY YOUR HOW
YOUR FATHER THEN WHEN YOU GET
MARRIED YOU'LL THEIR HOUSE SIGN
AND THEN WHEN YOU GET OLDER YOU
I EXCUSE ME YOUR SPOUSE AND THEN
WHEN YOU GET.
OLDER YOU'LL BE YOUR SIGN AND
THAT WAS THE CONFUSION TEACHING
AND SO THAT'S DEEPLY ROOTED IN
OUR COMMUNITY.
SO WHAT WE DO IS WE TALK ABOUT
WHAT ARE THE HEALTHY PARTS OF
OUR COMMUNITY AND OUR CURRENT
CREAM CULTURE THAT WE WANT TO
KEEP.
AND WE DO IT WE DO EMBRACE THE
IDEA OF IMP FM FOR EXAMPLE
RESPECTING YOUR ELDERS AND THAT
IS SOMETHING THAT IS AND THAT
THE FAMILY UNIT AND HOW
IMPORTANT THAT IS BUT THEN WE
START UNPACK SOME OF THE THINGS
THAT ARE NOT HEALTHY ABOUT IT.
SO WE TALK ABOUT GENDER NORMS
AND WHEN YOU TRY TO PUT THE MAN
FIRST HOW THAT IS SOME OF THE
THE REASONS WHY DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE OCCURS IS BECAUSE THIS
THIS POWER IMBALANCE AND THE
IMPORTANCE OF RESPECTING ONE MAN.
IN THE SAME WAY THAT YOU RESPECT
MAN AND SO IT IS.
IT IS CHALLENGING BECAUSE
SOMETIMES PEOPLE FEEL THAT.
THAT RESPECTING THE MAN IS
ROOTED IN OUR CREAM CULTURE AND
SO WE TRY TO TEACH THAT NO --
CREAM CULTURES.
NECESSARILY A BALLOT FEES ON
HEALTHY GENDER.
NORMS IN DYNAMICS BUT IT IS
LET'S PROMOTE SOME OF THE
HEALTHIER PARTS OF OF THAT OUT
OF THAT WE LIKE ABOUT THE
COMMUNITY AND NOT OTHERS.
THERE USED O BE A KOREAN SAYING
BACK IN THE DAY AND IT WENT
SOMETHING LIKE -- YOU TREAT EACH
YEAR WOMEN AND THERE'S A DRIED
FISH THAT KOREANS EAT IN THE
SAME WAY THEY SHOULD BE BEATEN
EVERY THREE DAYS BECAUSE THIS
FISH NEEDS TO BE POUNDED IN
ORDER TO BE SOFT ENOUGH TO EAT.
AS WE TALK ABOUT HOW THAT USED
TO BE THE NORM IN OUR CREAM
COMMUNITY BACK WELL MANY MANY
DECADES AGO BUT WE SAY HOW
FOOLISH AND HOW WRONG THAT IS
NOW AND PEOPLE.
CAN AGREE WITH THAT THAT WE HAVE
EVOLVED FROM THAT SO IT'S
CONTINUING TO TALK ABOUT HOW WE
NEED TO EVOLVE OUR CULTURE AND
THAT IF WE WANT TO ADDRESS
THINGS LIKE DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
AND SOCIAL SEXUAL ASSAULT.
WE CANNOT CONTINUE TO HAVE THESE
PATRIARCHAL GENDER NORMS AND I
THINK PEOPLE ARE STARTING TO SEE
THAT WHEN THEY SEE WHAT.
WHAT THE IMPACT HOUSE ON THE
FAMILY?
AND IF I'M AT MY MAY RESPOND TO
SOME OF THE OTHER COMMENTS --
BUT YOU KNOW I DO APPRECIATE YOU
SHARING WHAT YOU SAID ABOUT WHAT
YOUR FAITH LEADER HAS SAID TO
YOU AS A CHILD AND WE'VE HEARD
COUNTLESS STORIES FROM OUR
SURVIVORS.
SOME LIKE THAT THAT ARE REALLY
DEVASTATING AND OTHERS WHERE
THEY'VE BEEN REALLY SUPPORTIVE --
TO THE THE SURVIVOR AND HER
CHILDREN.
AND IT MAKES A NIGHT AND DAY
DIFFERENCE THE WAY YOUR FACE
LEADER RESPONDS YOU KNOW PEOPLE
HAVE LOST THEIR FAITH IN GOD IF
THEY HAVE NOT BEEN TREATED AND
SUPPORTED DURING THEIR MOMENTS
OF CRISIS.
AND OTHERS HAVE BEEN REINFORCED
IN THEIR FAITH -- BECAUSE OF
WHAT'S HAPPENED AND GONE ON TO
HELP OTHERS AND SO WE DO SEE IT
SO POWERFUL WHEN THE FAITH
LEADERS CAN HAVE SO MUCH
INFLUENCE.
IN IN IN CREATING A BETTER
SITUATION OR WERE SITUATION AND
I THINK WE'RE SEEING THAT AT
MORE ADVOCATES REALIZING THAT AS
WELL.
BECAUSE WE'RE GETTING MORE AND
MORE REQUESTS FOR TRAINING FROM
ADVOCATES IN ALL DIFFERENT
CULTURES AND COMMUNITIES ONE
NEED TO KNOW WHAT OUR BEST
PRACTICES AND STRATEGIES ARE.
BECAUSE WHAT'S INTERESTING IS NO
MATTER HOW DIFFERENT OUR
CULTURES ARE SOME OF THE
STRATEGIES AND THE WAY YOU WANT
TO BUILD THE BRIDGE WITH FAITH
LEADERS.
ARE IN MANY WAYS UNIVERSAL.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS KATE THEN WE CAN
CONTINUE WITH DANIEL THANK YOU
DONNA FOR OF PATIENTLY WAITING.
GOOD MORNING EVERYONE THANK YOU
FOR HAVING ME -- MY NAME IS
DANIEL MARTINEZ I WORK AT THE
LGBT Q. CENTER LONG BEACH AS A
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE COUNSELOR
ADVOCATE -- LITTLE HISTORY ABOUT
ME I WILL SAY I DID -- POST
GRADUATING I DID TWO YEARS OF
WORKING IN BETTER THAN A MENTOR
PROGRAMS SO INTERVENTION
PROGRAMS WITH WITH -- BATTERS
MAINLY MALE A LAND NECKS
IDENTIFIED -- FROM THERE I GOT
HURT AT THE TO BE TQ CENTER
BECAUSE OF THAT JOB BECAUSE THEY
WANTED TO START DOING PREVENTION
WORK PRE THEM GOING INTO THE
CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM -- SO AT
THE LGBT Q. CENTER WE ARE ONE OF
TO DOMESTIC VIOLENCE SERVICE
PROVIDERS THAT SPECIFIC
SPECIFICALLY -- WORK WITH THE
LGBT Q. PLUS -- IDENTITIES.
SO WHAT WE DO THERE -- A LOT OF
PEOPLE DON'T THINK THAT.
THEY'LL TO BE TOO CUTE COMMUNITY
CLOSER TO MESSI BALANCE
INCLUDING THE LGBTQ COMMUNITY
THEMSELVES SO THE WAY WE GET
CLIENTS THERE IS THEY COME
FUNNELED THROUGH THE MENTAL
HEALTH -- DEPARTMENT WHICH THEY
WANT TO DO COUPLES COUNSELING SO
FROM THERE THEY ARE SENT TO US.
AND WE DO AN ASSESSMENT
EVENTUALLY TO SEE IF THEY ARE
ARE FIT -- FOR COUPLES
COUNSELLING WE DO NOTICE THAT A
LOT OF TIMES -- COUPLES WANT TO
TO COUPLES COUNSELING THERE IS
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE IN THE
RELATIONSHIP SO WE FEEL LIKE
IT'S UNSAFE TO PUT THEM IN A
ROOM TOGTHER JUST TO BASICALLY.
LIKE LIKE WE SAID ERROR OUT
THEIR LAUNDRY AND THEN GO BACK
HOME AND SOMETHING MIGHT HAPPEN --
MY CUT SAID THAT ALSO MEN GO
THROUGH DOMESTIC VIOLENCE AND IT
IS TRUE MEN ALSO WATER TO MY
CERVANTES AND ALONG WITH OUR
CHANCE IDENTIFIED PEOPLE AND OR
NON CONFORMING PEOPLE -- IT IS
REALLY HARD FOR FOR PEOPLE TO
GET SERVICES -- JUST BECAUSE
SPECIALLY WITH VICTIMS FOR
SHELTER THAT THEY WE WE SENT A
CHANCE ON THE TO A SHELTER A LOT
OF TIMES SHELTERS WILL TAKE THEM
IN BECAUSE THEY DON'T KNOW HOW.
TO HANDLE A TRANS WOMAN THERE
LIKE WHEN THEY WERE BORN MALE
WHAT DO WE DO WHAT WE PUT THEM
WE DON'T KNOW IF WE SHOULD PUT
THEM WITH THE WOMEN ARE THE MEN --
ALSO MY TYPE WORK IS I DO LIKE I
SAID TO OUR PREVENTION SO WHAT
WE DO IS ONCE WE SEE THE COUPLES
ARE.
CAPABLE OF DOING COUPLES
COUNSELLING WE SEPARATE THEM
FIRST WE WAITED BUYS THEM TO DO
INDIVIDUAL CASTING.
I USUALLY GET THE PEOPLE THAT
ARE A LITTLE MORE ON THE
AGGRESSIVE SIDE AND THE TO
INDIVIDUAL COUNSELING WITH ME.
AND ALSO A STRESS IMPAIRMENT AS
JUST A POWER MANAGEMENT GROUP
THAT I THAT I RUN -- I BELIEVE
THAT MY WORKIS REALLY IMPORTANT
JUST BECAUSE WE I'VE SEEN SO
MANY CHANGES IN AND INDIVIDUALS
EITHER WANTED TO MAKE CHANGES IN
THE RELATIONSHIP REALIZING THAT
THEIR THEIR BEHAVIORS ARE ARE
ABUSIVE AND AND NOT HEALTHY.
AND THAT THEY SHOULD BE DOING
THEM ALSO -- I RARELY WORK WITH
SOME VICTIMS BUT WHEN I DO WORK
WITH VICTIMS ALL THAT KIND OF
WORK THAT I DO IS REALLY
IMPORTANT -- AND I FEEL LIKE WE
ESPECIALLY.
SORRY-- MY MY AGENCY WE REALLY
NEED THIS FUNDING JUST BECAUSE
THERE'S ONLY TWO OF US WORKING
ON MYSELF AND MY BOSS DOING THIS
KIND OF WORK AND MY AGENCIES SO
WHENEVER ONE OF US HAS TO LEAVE.
THERE'S ONLY ONE PERSISTENT BACK
IN THE OFFICE AND WE HAVE A
BUNCH OF CLIENTS THAT WE HAVE TO
SEE SO HAVING TO CANCEL CLIENT
IS REALLY IS REALLY HARD FOR FOR
THEM IN BECAUSE IT'S REALLY
CRUCIAL WORK THAT WE DO WE'RE
ALWAYS THERE FOR THEM
[inaudible]
IN.
WITH THAT THANK YOU FOR BEING
HERE I KNOW YOU LEFT YOUR BOSS
BY HIMSELF TO HIS.
YES BUT THANK YOU ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS ON FROM THE THE
COMMITTEE [inaudible]
COMMENTS.
CAN YOU TELL US A LITTLE BIT
MORE ABOUT ESPECIALLY GIVEN
THERE'S ONLY TWO OF YOU SERVING
THIS WORK -- AT YOUR AGENCY HOW
MANY OTHER AGENCIES THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA DO THIS WORK AND
WHERE THEY LOCATED BECAUSE BEING
IN THE BAY AREA I KNOW WE
PROBABLY HAVE A HUGE NEED FOR
THIS KIND OF SUPPORT FOR
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE VICTIMS AS
WELL.
YEAH SO UNFORTUNATELY THE TWO
AGENCIES IS LGBT Q. CENTER OF
LONG BEACH AND LGBT Q. CENTER OF
LOS ANGELES SO THAT BOTH
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA.
WE HAVE NO SUS PORT FOR THOSE.
SPECIFIC CULTURALLY RELEVANT
SUPPORT FOR LGBT Q. DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE SURVIVORS IN THE BAY
AREA EXACTLY.
CHAU A LOT OF THAT A LOT OF
OTHER AGENCIES BRING WANT -- TO
BASICALLY GIVE US WANT US TO
GIVE THEM TRAINING ON HOW TO
WORK WITH WITH THIS POPULATION
AND LIKE I SAID LIKE MY AGENCIES
ONLY TWO OF US IS ONLY SOME SO
MANY WAYS WE CAN BE STRETCHED
OUT.
THANK YOU FOR DOING THIS WORK I
KNOW IT'S IMPORTANT TO THE GAME
YOU'RE SERVING THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU FOR THE INFORMATION
YOU'VE SHARED WITH US I WAS
CURIOUS M. YOU'VE YOU DESCRIBE
SOME OF THE CHALLENGES.
THAT EXIST IN SERVING ABROAD
POPULATION INCLUDING MEMBERS OF
OUR LGBT COMMUNITY DO YOU HAVE
ANY SUGGESTIONS ON ELEMENTS ARE
THINGS THAT COULD BE DIFFERENT
THAT WOULD FACILITATE.
A MORE EFFECTIVE WAY TO SERVE
OUR LGBT COMMUNITY WHO COME IN
THROUGH -- CENTERS ARE NON
PROFITS YEAH.
YES SO DEFINITELY I KNOW LIKE
THIS MOVEMENT HAS BEEN VERY --
BINARY WHEN IT COMES TO WOMEN
ARE ARE VICTIMS MANNER ARE
USUALLY THE BATTERS AND WHEN IT
COMES TO THE LGBTQ COMMUNITY
IT'S MORE COMPLEX.
RIGHT BECAUSE THERE'S DIFFERENT
TYPES OF IDENTITIES -- SEX
ORIENTATION AND GENDER IDENTITY
AND A LOT OF PEOPLE TEND TO TO
GET CONFUSED WHEN IT COMES TO
THIS RIGHT YOU KNOW LET'S SAY
THERE IS -- A LESBIAN COUPLE
RIGHT AND THERE'S SOMETHING THAT
HAPPENS ONE IS MORE MASCULINE
PRESENTING WITH MORE FEMALE
PRESENTING SOMETIMES WHEN WHEN --
LAW ENFORCEMENT GETS INVOLVED
THEY AUTOMATICALLY ASSUME THAT
THE MORE MASCULINE PRESENTING --
WOMAN IS THE AGGRESSOR JUST
BECAUSE OF OUR OUR GENDER NORMS
SO DEFINITELY THINKING OUTSIDE
THE BOX WHEN IT COMES TO TO
ROLES -- WOMEN CAN BE ABUSIVE AS
WELL -- AND ANYONE CAN BE
ABUSIVE RIGHT ANYONE CAN FALL
INTO INTO THIS THIS ROLE IT'S
JUST IT'S JUST ALL ABOUT --
LEARNING THESE BEHAVIORS AND ON
LEARNING -- UNHEALTHY ONES
[inaudible]
MS RIVER.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM CHAIR
AND THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY TO BE TO BOTH OF YOU
IT'S REALLY -- A PRIVILEGE TO
HAVE YOU HERE.
MY QUESTION IS DO WE HAVE ANY --
STATISTICS ARE DO YOU GUYS
COLLECT ANY STATISTICS OR DATA
AND IS ANY RESEARCH BEEN DONE
SPECIFICALLY ON DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE IN THE LGBTQ COMMUNITY
THAT WE COULD LOOK TO AND SORT
OF GET A SENSE OF WHERE IT'S
WORDS OCCURRING WHAT TYPE WHAT
TYPES OF IDENTITIES AND
RELATIONSHIPS.
YEAH SO THERE IS I DON'T HAVE
ANY ON ME BACK CAN DEFINITELY
GET YOU IN TOUCH WITH ALL THAT --
MY ORGANIZATION IS A PART OF AND
TV P. A NATIONAL COALITION -- TO
ONLY GOT A FORGOTTEN SORRY ROSE
BUT I CAN DEFINITELY GET YOU
THAT INFORMATION -- EVERY YEAR
WE WE DO A CONFERENCE WHERE WE
MEET UP WE SEND ALL OF OUR
SYRTIS STATISTICS ALONG WITH
OTHERS.
FROM THE THE COUNTRY THAT YOU
KNOW WORK SPECIFICALLY WITH --
LGBT Q. A DV AND WE ALL THIS
TOGETHER AND CREATE -- ALL THE
OTHER DATA AND I CAN DEFINITELY
GET THAT FOR YOU YEAH THAT WOULD
BE GREAT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS.
KATE THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
YOUR PRESENTATION AND YOU KNOW
IF YOU CAN PROVIDE THAT
INFORMATION TO THE WHOLE.
IF YOU -- WANT TO GO THROUGH A
MONICA WE WILL MAKE SURE THAT
THE REST OF THE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS GET THAT INFORMATION.
AND THANK YOU FOR YOUR TESTIMONY
KATE THANK YOU NEXT OUR PANEL
THREE WE HAVE -- THE TITLES
ENGAGING INFLUENTIAL ADULTS AND
PEERS AND INFLUENTIAL ADULTS ALL
INCLUDES -- ELECTIVES -- AND SO
I A I THINK THIS IS DIRECTLY IT
TOWARDS US IF WE CAN HAVE KERR.
PERSON RAMBO AND VIRGINIA TO
PLACES -- PLEASE COME UP REALLY
APPRECIATE THAT.
VIRGINIA WOULD LIKE TO START
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
OKAY I'M EXT CHRISTEN
[inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
GOOD MORNING.
MY NAME IS KRISTEN RAMBO.
AND I'M THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
OF STAND STRONG.
A DOMESTIC VIOLENCE ORGANIZATION
IN SAN LUIS OBISPO COUNTY.
I AM NEWISH TO CALIFORNIA I
MOVED HERE ABOUT TWO AND A HALF
YEARS AGO FROM ATLANTA GEORGIA.
SO THIS IS MY FIRST TIME IN YOUR
CAPITOL BUILDING AND IT'S
BEAUTIFUL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FOR HAVING ME AND FOR
HOLDING THIS HEARING AND THANK
YOU ESPECIALLY TO YOU.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER RUBIO FOR
SHARING THIS COMMITTEE AND FOR
GIVING VOICE TO THIS ISSUE.
IN ATLANTA I WORKED AT THE US
CENTERS FOR DISEASE CONTROL AND
PREVENTION THE CDC.
WHICH AS YOU KNOW IS THE
NATION'S PUBLIC HEALTH AGENCY.
MANY PEOPLE DON'T KNOW THAT IN
ADDITION TO ADDRESSING THINGS
LIKE FLU AND EBOLA.
THE CDC ALSO HAS A DIVISION OF
VIOLENCE PREVENTION.
AND THAT IS BECAUSE VIOLENCE IS
A LEADING CAUSE OF INJURY AND
DEATH IN THIS COUNTRY.
SO FOR THAT REASON IT REQUIRES A
PUBLIC HEALTH APPROACH AND THE
GOAL IS TO TRULY PREVENT THE
VIOLENCE. TO STOP IT BEFORE IT
EVEN STARTS.
IN THE DIVISION OF VIOLENCE
PREVENTION I LED THE CDC'S
NATIONAL DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
PREVENTION PROGRAM.
IN THAT ROLE I GOT TO SEE WHAT
VIOLENCE PREVENTION LOOKS LIKE
IN STATES AND COMMUNITIES ACROSS
THE COUNTRY.
AND I LEARNED A LOT OF THINGS
THERE THAT HAVE CARRIED THROUGH
IN MY ROLE IT STANDS STRONG HERE
IN CALIFORNIA. FOR ONE THING I
LEARNED MORE ABOUT A PROGRAM
CALLED COACHING BOYS INTO MEN.
WE ARE VERY FORTUNATE TO BE
IMPLEMENTING THIS PROGRAM IN SAN
LUIS OBISPO COUNTY.
THIS IS A PROGRAM WORKING WITH
HIGH SCHOOL AGE MALE ATHLETES
BUILDING ON THEIR STRENGTHS AS
LEADERS AND INFLUENCERS IN THEIR
PEER GROUPS. TO CHANGE THE
CULTURE ON THAT TEAM IN THAT
SCHOOL IN THEIR PEER GROUP.
IN THEIR COMMUNITY.
THE CHARACTERISTICS THAT
ATHLETES OFTEN LEARN ON THE
FIELD OR ON HE COURT.
SUCH AS LEADERSHIP RESPECT AND
COOPERATION.
CAN ALSO TRANSLATE INTO SKILLS
FOR PROMOTING HEALTHY
RELATIONSHIPS WHETHER IT'S WITH
YOU KNOW OTHERS IN THEIR LIFE
PARENTS PEERS AND CURRENT OR
FUTURE ROMANTIC PARTNERS AS YOU.
DISCUSS IT'S NOT ALWAYS THAT
ROMANTIC PARTNER COULD BE
FRIENDS.
SINCE COACHING BOYS INTO MEN
BEGAN IN TWO THOUSAND ONE
THOUSANDS OF COACHES AROUND THE
WORLD HAVE SIGNED ON AND WHAT'S
EVEN MORE EXCITING.
IS THAT THIS PROGRAM HAS BEEN
RIGOROUSLY TESTED AND EVALUATED.
AND THE RESULTS ARE SOME VERY
ENCOURAGING OUTCOMES.
IN THIS STUDY THAT INCLUDED
SIXTEEN HIGH SCHOOLS AND OVER
TWO THOUSAND ATHLETES THE
RESULTS SHOW THAT ATHLETES WHO
PARTICIPATED IN THE PROGRAM NOT
ONLY HAD GREATER INTENTIONS TO
INTERVENE.
WHEN THEY SAW ABUSIVE AND
DISRESPECTFUL BEHAVIOR AMONG
THEIR PEERS BUT THEY ACTUALLY
DID SPEAK UP AND INTERVENE IN
THESE SITUATIONS AT HIGHER RATES?
THAN THOSE WHO HAD NOT BEEN
THROUGH THE PROGRAM.
NOT ONLY THAT BUT EVEN A YEAR
AFTER COMPLETING THE PROGRAM.
THOSE WHO HAD PARTICIPATED IN
THE PROGRAM HAD LOWER RATES OF
ABUSE PERPETRATION.
AND LOWER RATES OF PASSIVELY
ALLOWING ABUSED TO HAPPEN AMONG
THEIR PEERS.
SO THIS RESEARCH TELLS US THAT
YES IT REALLY IS POSSIBLE. TO
STOP GENDER BASED VIOLENCE
BEFORE IT STARTS AND THAT YES WE
ARE ON THE RIGHT TRACK.
IN SAN LUIS OBISPO COUNTY WE'RE
IMPLEMENTING THIS PROGRAM INTO
HIGH SCHOOL SO FAR. ONE CATHOLIC
HIGH SCHOOL IN ONE PUBLIC HIGH
SCHOOL.
AT ONE OF THE SCHOOLS WE ARE
WORKING WITH A VOLLEY BALL A
GOLF AND THE BASEBALL TEAM RIGHT
NOW.
AND WE'RE ADDING FOOTBALL IN THE
FALL.
ALTHOUGH IT'S EARLY ON WE'RE
ALREADY SEEING SOME ANECDOTAL
EVIDENCE OF THE IMPACT THAT THIS
PROGRAM IS HAVING.
COACHES HAVE SHARED THAT THEY'VE
NOTICED DIFFERENCES IN THEIR
TEAMS MOSTLY IN THE LANGUAGE
THAT THEY USE.
AND HOW THEY HOLD EACH OTHER
ACCOUNTABLE FOR THEIR ACTIONS
AND FOR THEIR WORDS.
THEY'VE ALSO NOTICED THIS
PROGRAM BRINGING TEAMS TOGETHER
AND GETTING THEM TO COMMUNICATE
ON A DEEPER LEVEL. ONE COACH
SHARE THAT AFTER DISCUSSING
HARMFUL LANGUAGE DURING ONE OF
THEIR COACHING BOYS INTO MEN
SESSIONS ONE STUDENT ACTUALLY
CALLED ANOTHER ONE OUT.
WHEN HE STARTED MAKING FUN OF
HIS TEAMMATES?
ANOTHER COACH HAS SEEN OLDER
PLAYERS RISE TO LEADERSHIP ROLES
IN THE PROGRAM SOMETIMES LEADING
DISCUSSIONS ON THESE TOPICS
SOMETIMES FOR OVER THIRTY
MINUTES.
HE SAID IT'S OBVIOUS THAT THE
ATHLETES WANT TO TALK ABOUT
THESE TOPICS.
BUT MANY OF THEM HAVE NEVER BEEN
GIVEN THE OPPORTUNITY OR THE
TOOLS TO COMMUNICATE THEIR
THOUGHTS AND FEELINGS TO ONE
ANOTHER.
PRIOR TO THIS PROGRAM.
ANOTHER COACH SHARE THAT WHEN HE
OVER HEARD A DISRESPECTFUL
DISCUSSION IN THE LOCKER ROOM HE
WAS PROUD TO HEAR ANOTHER
STUDENT CHIME IN TO SAY THAT HEY
WE SHOULD BE SAYING THAT STUFF.
NOW WHENEVER I TELL PEOPLE ABOUT
COACHING BOYS INTO MEN THEY
ALWAYS SAY THAT'S AWESOME FOR
THE BOYS.
WHAT ABOUT THE GIRLS?
IT WAS REALLY HARD TO FIND
FUNDING TO DO SOMETHING SIMILAR
WITH GIRLS.
WE HAD A LOT OF GOOD IDEAS AND
PLANS AND WE HAD THE PERFECT
INFRASTRUCTURE.
BECAUSE WE WERE ALREADY SET UP
TO DO THE SAME WORK WITH BOYS
THEIR COACHING BOYS INTO MEN.
BUT WE WERE NOT ABLE TO
IMPLEMENTED BECAUSE THERE SIMPLY
IS NOT A LOT OF FUNDING OUT
THERE FOR PREVENTION.
PREVENTION CAN BE HARDER TO
UNDERSTANDING GRAB HOLD OF THEM
WHAT FOLKS ARE USED TO FUNDING.
WHICH IS HOW TO INTERVENE AFTER
THE DAMAGE HAS BEEN DONE.
AS A SOCIETY WERE OFTEN MUCH
BETTER AT HELPING OUT AFTER THE
FACT.
WHAT SAVE THE DAY FOR US FINALLY
WAS THE FAMILY VIOLENCE
PREVENTION GRANT FOR THE FX
GRANT FROM CALLOW YES THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE OF EMERGENCY
SERVICES?
I'M EXTREMELY HAPPY TO TELL YOU
THAT WE ARE NOW ABLE TO
IMPLEMENT A PROGRAM FOR HIGH
SCHOOL AGE GIRLS.
CALL ATHLETES AS LEADERS.
THAT WAS DESIGNED AS THE
COMPANION PROGRAM TO COACHING
BOYS INTO MEN.
AND EVEN THOUGH THAT GRANT JUST
STARTED WE ALREADY HAVE A GIRLS
VOLLEYBALL TEAM AND A ROLLER
DERBY TEAM.
ON BOARD TO IMPLEMENT THE
ATHLETES AS LEADERS PROGRAM.
WE'RE EXTREMELY GRATEFUL FOR
THIS FUNDING AND FOR THE
FORESIGHT AND A COMMITMENT FROM
THE LEGISLATURE THAT HAS MADE
THIS POSSIBLE BECAUSE WE SIMPLY
COULD NOT DO THIS WORK WITHOUT
THIS FUNDING FROM CALLOW YES.
AND THAT'S ANOTHER LESSON THAT I
LEARNED IN MY TIME AT CDC.
I LEARNED THAT STATE FUNDING IS
ESSENTIAL FOR THE SUCCESS OF
VIOLENCE PREVENTION EFFORTS.
WITHOUT THESE FUNDS THERE IS
JUST A VERY LITTLE FINANCIAL
SUPPORT FOR VIOLENCE PREVENTION
AND PARTICULARLY FOR SEXUAL AND
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE PREVENTION.
EVEN THAT GREAT CDC FUNDING
WHICH WE TALKED ABOUT A LITTLE
BIT HERE TODAY WHICH IS
WONDERFUL.
IS LESS THAN SIX MILLION DOLLARS
NATIONWIDE.
IT ONLY FUNDS TEN STATES.
AND WE'RE LUCKY THAT
CALIFORNIA'S ONE OF THEM.
BUT EACH OF THOSE TEN STATES ARE
LIMITED TO WORKING WITH THAT
FUNDING IN ONLY TWO COMMUNITIES.
SO THAT FUNDING IS A GREAT START.
BUT IT'S NOT AND REALLY NOT
INTENDED TO BE.
ALL ENCOMPASSING AND I'M
ACTUALLY HAPPY TO ANSWER MORE
QUESTIONS ABOUT THAT LATER IF
YOU LIKE -- BUT YOU KNOW OFTEN
IT'S EASIER FOR FUNDERS TO
UNDERSTAND.
PAYING FOR NIGHTS AT THE SHELTER
FOR CHILD CARE YOU KNOW THOSE
THINGS THAT FEEL MORE IMMEDIATE
AND FEEL MORE TANGIBLE.
AND I REALLY UNDERSTAND
PERSONALLY WHY IT FEELS GOOD TO
FUND THOSE THINGS AND THOSE
THINGS ARE ABSOLUTELY VITAL --
BUT AS WE LOOK DOWN THE ROAD.
IF WE WANT TO REACH A DAY WHERE
WE NO LONGER HAVE TO FIND
SHELTERS. TO A FUTURE WHERE NO
ONE HAS TO LEAVE HOME BECAUSE
THEY'RE BEING TERRORIZED BY
SOMEONE WHO CLAIMS TO LOVE THEM.
WE HAVE TO INVEST NOW IN
PREVENTION.
FUNDING PREVENTION IS A SMART
LONG TERM INVESTMENT AND IT IS
AN INVESTMENT IN OUR CHILDREN.
IN OUR COMMUNITIES.
AND IN OUR FUTURE [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FOR ME QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
YES MISSED THE TRAINERS.
SIR COULD NOT AGREE WITH YOU
MORE AND I THINK WE WE KNOW THAT.
PREVENTION IS ALWAYS BETTER THAN
CARE YET YOUR TIME AND AGAIN IN
ISSUE AFTER ISSUE WE DON'T
INVEST IN PREVENTION WE WAIT FOR
THERE TO BE A CRISIS -- SIX
THANK YOU FOR THE WORK THAT
YOU'RE DOING AND SOUNDS LIKE YOU
HAVE HAD SOME VERY EXCITING
SUCCESS APPRECIATE AND IN
PARTICULAR I THINK YOUR EVIDENCE.
I YOUR EVIDENCE BASED APPROACH.
SAID YOU'RE CURRENTLY OPERATING
IN TO COMMUNITIES ARE THAT THE
FUNDING THAT YOU HAVE RIGHT NOW.
IS SUFFICIENT FOR YOU TO OPERATE
IN TO COMMUNITIES.
WE'RE IN TWO HIGH SCHOOLS RIGHT
NOW TO HIGH SCHOOL WITH OUR
COACHING BOYS INTO MEN PROGRAM
AND WE'RE LOOKING TO ADD MORE
HIGH SCHOOLS TO THAT.
AND THEN WE HAVE OUR ATHLETES AS
LEADERS PROGRAM STARTED MORE
RECENTLY BECAUSE THAT'S A GRANT
THAT JUST STARTED FOR US -- AND
THAT'S THE ONE THROUGH THE THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE OF EMERGENCY
SERVICES AND THAT'S THE PROGRAM
FOR THE FEMALE IDENTIFIED
ATHLETES -- AND THROUGH THAT WE
HAVE ONE ADDITIONAL HIGH SCHOOL --
WHERE WILL BE DOING THE GIRLS
VOLLEYBALL AND THEN A NON HIGH
SCHOOL SETTING WHICH IS THE
ROLLER DERBY?
AND HAVE YOU.
THOUGHT AT ALL ABOUT WHAT IT
WOULD TAKE.
TO EXPAND THAT.
OF COURSE OF COURSE YEAH WE OKAY
I THINK ABOUT THAT ALL THE TIME --
WE'RE VERY GRATEFUL FOR THE
FUNDING THAT WE HAVE BUT WE ALSO
KNOW THAT -- IN TERMS OF WHAT
NEEDS TO BE DONE IT SORT OF JUST
A DROP IN THE BUCKET -- WITH THE
WITH THE FEDERAL FUNDING THE CDC
FUNDING WE DO HOPE TO EXPAND TO
MORE SCHOOLS HOPING TO
EVENTUALLY GET. TO FIVE FOR THE
MALE IDENTIFIED ATHLETES AND
THAT -- WITH THE ATHLETES AS
LEADERS I DON'T I DON'T KNOW YET
WHAT THAT HOLDS BECAUSE IT'S
STILL A NEWER PROCESS BUT I MEAN
YOU THINK ABOUT THE NUMBER OF
SCHOOLS IN ANY GIVEN COMMUNITY.
AND OF COURSE IT WOULD TAKE A
LOT MORE TO BE ABLE TO REALLY
REACH ALL THE SCHOOLS THAT AND
ONE THING WE KNOW ABOUT
PREVENTION IS THAT -- YOU HAVE.
TO REALLY GET IN THERE AND SORT
OF GO DEEP WE CAN'T SORT OF
SPRINKLE IT DOWN FROM THE
DISTRICT LEVEL WE HAVE TO GO
INTO THE SCHOOLS WE HAVE TO WORK
WITH THE COACHES WHO THEN.
WORK WITH THE ATHLETES AND SO --
UNFORTUNATELY THERE'S NOT A SORT
OF BROAD.
TOP DOWN THING THAT WE CAN DO IT
REALLY IS A MATTER.
OF GOING INTO EACH SCHOOL.
AND WORKING WITH THOSE COACHES
IN WITH THOSE TEAMS TO CHANGE
THAT CULTURE WITH THE HOPE THAT.
THE COACHES ARE INFLUENCERS FOR
THE ATHLETES THE ATHLETES ARE
INFLUENCERS FOR THEIR PEERS AND
THAT IT SPREADS THAT WAY.
AND BEYOND.
HELP WITH SECURING FUNDING ARE
THERE THINGS THAT WE CAN DO.
AS LEGISLATORS THAT COULD HELP
YOU AMPLIFY THE WORK THAT YOU'RE
DOING.
THANK YOU FOR THAT QUESTION
THAT'S WONDERFUL -- AND I
APPRECIATE THE COMMENT BEFORE WE
GOT HERE THAT -- YES WE TALK
ABOUT AGING INFLUENTIAL ADULTS
AND YOU ALL ARE CERTAINLY SOME
INFLUENTIAL ADULTS -- ANOTHER
COMPONENT OF OUR OF OUR WORK IS
ASKING MEMBERS OF THE COMMUNITY.
WHO ARE SEEN AS LEADERS IN THE
COMMUNITY WHETHER THEY BE FAITH
LEADERS WHETHER THEY BE -- YOU
KNOW BUSINESS PEOPLE WHAT
WHATEVER SECTOR THERE FROM -- TO
STAND WITH US AND TO HELP CREATE
THIS COMMUNITY WHERE WE SAY WE
DON'T TOLERATE.
THIS VIOLENCE AND WE DON'T
TOLERATE THE TYPES OF WORDS OR
ACTIONS THAT PROMOTE AND SUPPORT
A CULTURE OF VIOLENCE AND SO
THAT'S ANOTHER ARM OF OUR
PREVENTION WORK.
AND AS WE LOOK TO WHO ARE THOSE
INFLUENTIAL ADULTS THAT NOT JUST
KIDS LOOK TO BUT THAT OTHER
ADULTS LOOK.
TO I CERTAINLY SEE A ROLE FOR
LEGISLATORS LEGISLATORS VERY
POWERFUL IN THEIR COMMUNITIES
AND HERE.
AT THE STATE LEVEL -- THERE'S
CERTAINLY A ROLE FOR LEGISLATORS
TO HELP US BE THAT VOICE TO SAY.
THIS IS WHAT.
THIS IS THE KIND OF PLACE I WANT
THIS COUNTY TO BE THIS COMMUNITY
TO BE THIS TOWN TO BE IN THE
STATE TO BE.
A PLATE YOU KNOW WEEK WE CAN
LEAD THE COUNTRY.
IN TERMS OF NOT TOLERATING
VIOLENCE IN TERMS OF OF
PROMOTING HEALTHY RELATIONS WAS
REALLY UNDERSTANDING.
AT A DEEP LEVEL WHAT THAT MEANS
A LIVING.
SO I THINK THERE'S A GREAT ROLE
THERE AND THAT IS.
SEPARATE FROM THE WHOLE FUNDING
QUESTION IN A LOT OF THAT.
LEGISLATORS CAN DO FOR FREE
RIGHT [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER QUESTIONS
COMMENTS OKAY THANK YOU BRITTANY.
GOOD MORNING OUT PROCESS ON YES
GOOD MORNING CHAIRMAN WOMAN
RUBIO AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE.
THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING ME TO
SHARE MY PERSPECTIVE AND SOME
IDEAS ABOUT HOW WE CAN WORK
TOGETHER TO PREVENT DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE ACROSS THE STATE.
MY NAME IS VIRGINIA DUE PROCESS
AND I'M A PROJECT DIRECTOR ON
THE HEALTH TEAM OUT FUTURES
WITHOUT VIOLENCE WE'RE A
NATIONAL HEALTH AND SOCIAL
JUSTICE NONPROFIT BASED IN SAN
FRANCISCO WITH ONE SIMPLE
MISSION. TO HEAL THOSE AMONG US
WHO ARE TRAUMATIZED BY VIOLENCE
TODAY AND TO CREATE HEALTHY
FAMILIES.
FREE OF VIOLENCE TOMORROW.
OUR GROUND BREAKING PROGRAMS
POLICY DEVELOPMENT AND PUBLIC
ACTION CAMPAIGNS ARE DESIGNED TO
PREVENT AN AND VIOLENCE AROUND
THE WORLD.
STRIVING TO REACH AUDIENCES AND
TRANSFORM SOCIAL NORMS WE
TRAINED PROFESSIONALS SUCH AS
DOCTORS NURSES JUDGES AND
ATHLETIC COACHES ON TAKING
ACTION TO ADDRESS VIOLENCE AND
ABUSE.
WE ALSO WORK WITH ADVOCATES
POLICYMAKERS AND OTHERS TO BUILD
SUSTAINABLE COMMUNITY LEADERSHIP
AND EDUCATE PEOPLE EVERYWHERE
ABOUT THE IMPORTANCE OF RESPECT
AND HEALTHY RELATIONSHIPS.
IN ADDITION TO MY OVER FIFTEEN
YEAR CAREER AND VIOLENCE
PREVENTION AND RESPONSE I COME
TO YOU AS A SURVIVOR.
AND AS A MOTHER OF A SIXTEEN
YEAR OLD DAUGHTER.
I'M COMMITTED TO PREVENTION WITH
THE HOPE THAT OTHERS IN MY
FAMILY AND COMMUNITY.
NEVER HAVE TO EXPERIENCE THE
FEAR ISOLATION AND SHAME THAT
WERE PART OF MY STORY.
BUT OF COURSE PREVENTION CAN BE
DONE BY ONE PERSON OR EVEN BY
ONE ORGANIZATION NO MATTER HOW
COMMITTED WE ARE.
EACH AND EVERYONE OF US HAS A
YOU HAS A UNIQUE AND IMPORTANT
ROLE IN PREVENTING DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE.
TODAY I'M GONNA TALK ABOUT A FEW
OF THE STRATEGIES THAT FUTURES
WITHOUT VIOLENCE HAS DEVELOPED
AND THAT WE SUPPORTED --
COMMUNITIES IN IMPLEENTING.
SO COACHING BOYS INTO MEN AND
ATHLETES AS LEADERS ARE TWO OF
OUR PROGRAMS -- IN ADDITION TO
HIGH SCHOOL ATHLETICS COACHING
BOYS INTO MEN IS ALSO BEING
PILOTED AT UC BERKELEY WITH
THREE SPORTS TEAMS.
WE KNOW THAT SPORTS CAN BE AN
IMPORTANT VEHICLE FOR SOCIAL
CHANGE AND HAVE DEVELOPED A
PARTNERSHIP WITH MAJOR LEAGUE
BASEBALL.
EACH SPRING FUTURE STAFF HEADS
TO FLORIDA AND ARIZONA TO
PROVIDE WORKSHOPS FOR EVERY MLB
TEAM'S FORTY MAN ROSTER WITH AN
EMPHASIS ON PREVENTION AND
BUILDING HEALTHY.
PASSED UP POSITIVE BYSTANDER.
AT BEHAVIORS WHETHER IT'S
INTERRUPTING SEXIST JOKES IN THE
LOCKER ROOM OR HOW TO SAFELY
INTERVENE IF THEY WITNESS A
PHYSICAL ALTERCATION.
WE KNOW THAT CHANGE TAKES TIME
BUT OVER THE FIVE YEARS WE'VE
BEEN WORKING WITH MAJOR LEAGUE
BASEBALL WE'VE SEEN THE CULTURE
SHIFTING.
PLAYERS WHO ARE IN OUR VERY
FIRST TRAININGS FIVE YEARS AGO
ARE NOW ACTING AS MENTORS AND
SUPPORT TO NEWER PLAYERS MAKING
SURE THAT THE NEW PLAYERS TAKE
THE WORKSHOP SERIOUSLY.
AND HOLD EACH OTHER ACCOUNTABLE
TO HIGH STANDARDS OF EQUITY AND
RESPECT.
BUT WE'RE MORE THAN JUST SPORTS.
OUR ORGANIZATION ACTUALLY
STARTED OFF AS A TINY OFFICE IN
THE BASEMENT OF SAN FRANCISCO
GENERAL HOSPITAL WHERE WE
SUPPORTED DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
SURVIVORS WHO ARE COMING TO THE
EMERGENCY ROOM.
SINCE THEN WE'VE EXPANDED TO A
NATIONAL PROGRAM THAT IT
INCLUDES RESEARCH TRAINING AND
RESOURCES FOR A WIDE RANGE OF
HEALTH CARE SETTINGS.
IN FACT FOR OVER TWENTY YEARS
WE'VE BEEN THE FEDERALLY
DESIGNATED NATIONAL RESOURCE
CENTER ON DOMESTIC VIOLENCE.
AND RECENTLY BECAME A PARTNER IN
THE BOND.
OF VIOLENCE PREVENTION TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE CENTER FOR AT THE CDC.
HERE IN CALIFORNIA WE LED THE
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE HEALTHCARE
PARTNERSHIP WHICH WAS FUNDED BY
BLUE SHIELD OF CALIFORNIA
FOUNDATION.
INCLUDED NINETEEN CLINICS FROM
ACROSS THE STATE THAT PARTNERED
WITH THEIR LOCAL DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE PROGRAMS TO BETTER
PREVENT AND RESPOND TO DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE.
HEALTHCARE PROVIDERS WERE
TRAINED ON HOW TO TALK WITH ALL
OF THEIR PATIENTS ABOUT HEALTHY
RELATIONSHIPS AND PROVIDE
INFORMATION ON ADVOCACY
RESOURCES.
SO INSTEAD OF JUST ASKING A
SCREENING QUESTION LIKE HAVE YOU
ARE YOU BEING HURT BY A PARTNER.
PROVIDERS IN THIS INITIATIVE
ACTUALLY STARTED WITH
CONVERSATIONS ABOUT CONSENT
RESPECT AND RELATIONSHIP SAFETY.
BOTH ARE QUANTITATIVE AND
QUALITATIVE DATA SHOW
IMPROVEMENTS FOR BOTH THE
PROVIDERS AND THE PATIENT'S.
PROVIDERS FELT MORE CONFIDENT
TALKING ABOUT DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
PREVENTION.
AND PATIENTS FELT MORE SUPPORTED
BY THEIR PROVIDERS.
MANY PATIENTS SHARED THAT THE
INTERACTION WITH THEIR PROVIDER
WAS THE FIRST TIME THAT ANYONE
IN THEIR LIVES HAD TALKED TO
THEM ABOUT WHAT.
HEALTHY AND SAFE RELATIONSHIP
MIGHT LOOK LIKE WHAT THEY
DESERVED.
AND HOW THEY DESERVE TO BE
TREATED IN A RELATIONSHIP AND
THEY ALSO SHARED THAT THEY WERE
TAKING THE INFORMATION BACK TO
THEIR FRIENDS AND FAMILY.
THIS IS WHERE WE SEE THE
INCREDIBLE RIPPLE EFFECT OF
PREVENTION WORK.
HEALTHCARE PROVIDERS TALKING
WITH PATIENTS WHO IN THE END WHO
IN TURN BRING THESE IMPORTANT
PREVENTION MESSAGES BACK TO
THEIR COMMUNITIES.
WE'VE ALSO SEEN GREAT REGIONAL
LEADERSHIP EMERGE SO THE CLINICS
IN THE DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
PARTNERSHIPS AND THE LOS ANGELES
AREA CONTINUE TO MEET AS A TASK
FORCE.
FOCUSED ON PREVENTION WORK EVEN
THOUGH THERE GRANT FUNDING HAS
ENDED AND I DID MY LITTLE GOOGLE
SEARCH WHILE FOLKS WERE SPEAKING
AND I KNOW THAT.
LOT OF THESE CLINICS IN TV
PROGRAMS ARE ACTUALLY IN
COMMUNITIES THAT -- SOME FOLKS
ON THIS COMMITTEE SERVICE SO YOU
MIGHT WANT TO BE IN TOUCH WITH
THEM TO TALK MORE ABOUT THEIR
WORK.
WORK PLACES ARE ANOTHER FORM OF
COMMUNITY WE SPEND MORE TIME
WORKING THAN ON ANY OTHER WAKING
ACTIVITY SO THE WORKPLACE
PRESENTS A CRITICAL OPPORTUNITY
FOR PREVENTION.
FUTURES WITHOUT VIOLENCE IS ALSO
HOME TO WORK PLACES RESPOND TO
DOMESTIC AND SEXUAL VIOLENCE AND
NATIONAL RESOURCE CENTER.
WHICH IS A PUBLIC PRIVATE
PARTNERSHIP FUNDED BY THE US
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE.
EMPLOYEE AND SUPERVISOR TRAINING
PROGRAMS AWARENESS RAISING
ACTIVITIES AND WORKPLACE
VIOLENCE POLICIES ARE JUST SOME
OF THE TOOLS THAT WORKPLACE
STAKEHOLDERS CAN UTILIZE TO
IMPLEMENT PROACTIVE MULTI
STAKEHOLDER PROGRAMS THAT NOT
ONLY RESPOND TO THE IMPACTS OF
VIOLENCE.
BUT WORK TOWARD PREVENTING IT IN
THE FIRST PLACE.
JUL SUCH AS ONE CALL CHECK YOUR
WORKPLACE ENCOURAGE
ORGANISATIONS TO START
CONVERSATIONS ABOUT PREVENTION
AND GETTING INPUT FROM WORKERS
AT ALL LEVELS. TO HELP CREATE A
CULTURE OF SAFETY AND RESPECT.
AND OF COURSE BEFORE ANY OF US
AND TO THE WORKPLACE WE HAVE TO
GO TO SCHOOL.
SO FUTURES WITHOUT VIOLENCE HAS
HELPED CREATE PREVENTION
PROGRAMS FROM EARLY CHILDHOOD.
K. TO TWELVE AND COLLEGE CAMPUS
SETTINGS -- SO FROM PRESCHOOL TO
PHD WE HAVE EVIDENCE BASED
STRATEGIES THAT CAN PREVENT
VIOLENCE BEFORE IT OCCURS. FOR
EXAMPLE ON OUR WORK WITH HEAD
STARTS.
WE'VE CREATED RESOURCES FOR
TEACHERS AND STAFF TO TALK WITH
ALL CARE GIVERS ABOUT HEALTHY
AND SAFE RELATIONSHIPS. FOR
MIDDLE SCHOOL WE HAVE A PROGRAM
CALLED START STRONG THAT AMONG
OTHER THINGS PROVIDES TOOLS FOR
PARENTS TO TALK TO THEIR KIDS
ABOUT DATING.
RELATIONSHIPS RESPECT AND
HEALTHY FRIENDSHIPS.
ON COLLEGE CAMPUSES WE CAN BE
LEADERSHIP INSTITUTES FOR
STUDENTS FACULTY AND STAFF TO
CREATE COMPREHENSIVE PREVENTION
PLANS.
AND ALTHOUGH WE BRING OUR OWN
TOOLS BUILT ON YEARS OF RESEARCH
AND ON THE GROUND EXPERIENCE WE
ALWAYS ENCOURAGE COMMUNITIES TO
ADAPT THEM TO MEET THEIR UNIQUE
NEEDS AND STRENGTHS.
PREVENTION IS POSSIBLE VIOLENCE
AND TRAUMA ARE NOT INEVITABLE
PARTS OF HUMAN EXPERIENCE.
WE HAVE CONCRETE STRATEGIES TO
HELP INDIVIDUALS AND COMMUNITIES
AROUND TO KEEP DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
AND HOPE THIS COMMITTEE WILL
HELP CREATE THOSE OPPORTUNITIES
TO IMPLEMENT THEM ACROSS THE
STATE.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU DO WE HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
LIKE THAT OUT FROM FROM THE
COMMITTEE.
THANK YOU I THANK YOU VERY MUCH
WILL OPEN IT UP FOR OUR FOR
ABOVE PUBLIC COMMENT BUT AGAIN
IF YOU CAN PROVIDE SOME OF THAT
INFORMATION TO US AND THAT WE
WILL DISTRIBUTE IT TO THE
COMMITTEE -- I'M INTERESTED IN
YOU KNOW THE THE PROGRAMS.
FOR ALL ALL SCHOOL AGE KIDS BY --
SPECIFICALLY ARE THE HEALTHY
RELATIONSHIPS I THINK WE TALKED
TOUCH.
WE TOUCHED ON IT EARLIER ABOUT --
SOME TEENS THINK THAT --
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE IS -- OR
VIOLENCE IS JUST INTO MY
PARTNERS BUT WE THAT CYCLE
STARTS WITH -- UNHEALTHY
RELATIONSHIPS JUST WITH FRIENDS
AND SO I THINK THAT IF WE CAN
FOCUS A LITTLE BIT ON ON THAT
TYPE OF TRAINING FOR OUR
STUDENTS ARE FOR KIDS.
THEN THE WILL LEARN THE
DIFFERENCE RIGHT AND NOT GET
INTO A DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
RELATIONSHIPS -- WITH INTIMATE
PARTNER SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE -- THE PANEL IN THE
WALL OPEN IT UP TO PUBLIC
COMMENT -- AND THEN -- HOPEFULLY
WE CAN.
AND WITH SOME TOOLS AND SOME
INFORMATION GATHERING SO THAT WE
CAN MAKE SOME OF THESE --
QUESTIONS AND POLICIES AND TO
ACTUAL REALITY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU [inaudible] THREE GOOD
MORNING MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE MY NAME IS KRISTEN
I'M SECOND WITH THE CALIFORNIA
PARTNERSHIP TO AND DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE SO AS MANY OF YOU KNOW
WHERE THE STATEWIDE ORGANIZATION
WERE BASED HERE IN SACRAMENTO --
AND GET THE TREMENDOUS PRIVILEGE
OF WORKING WITH ALL OF THESE
ORGANIZATIONS AND SO MANY OTHERS
DOING GREAT PREVENTION WORK
ACROSS THE STATE -- JUST WANNA
REALLY APPRECIATE THE HEARING
TODAY THANK YOU ALL FOR BEING
HERE.
WE HAVE PROVIDED ALL OF YOU WITH
SOME MATERIALS ABOUT THE GREAT
WORK THEY'RE DOING THERE'S SOME
MORE OUTSIDE INCLUDING SOME
AWESOME STICKERS THAT ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GIPSON IS ROCKING FOR YOU.
BUT JUST WANTED TO YOU KNOW MAKE
SURE YOU ALL KNOW THAT WE ARE
HERE AS A RESOURCE -- TO HELP
CONNECT ALL OF YOU WITH THE
GREAT WORK HAPPENING IN YOUR
DISTRICTS -- AND THINK ABOUT
STATEWIDE IMPACT THAT WE CAN
MAKE HERE AT THE CAPITOL.
THANK YOU THANK YOU ANY OTHER
COMMENTS QUESTIONS.
OKAY WILL SEEN AND I WOULD LIKE
TO I THINK THE THE PANELS OFF
PARTICIPATING -- IT'S CRUCIAL
THAT WE INVEST -- SOME
CONVERSATION TIME BUT I THINK --
MORE THAN THAT IS TO INVEST.
TRANSFORM THAT CONVERSATION INTO
SOME ACCENTS AND I HEARD REALLY
GREAT PROGRAMS I'M REALLY GOOD
WORK THAT'S HAPPENING THROUGHOUT
THE STATE.
AND WE WERE SHOCKED TO HEAR THAT
SOME OF THESE PROGRAMS ARE NOT
IN OUR NAME -- AS AN NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA AND SO THE THE HOPE
IS THAT WE CAN REPLICATE SOME OF
YOUR AMAZING AMAZING PROGRAMS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE -- I HEARD --
I THINK THE MAIN TOPIC WAS A
BALLOT HEALTHY RELATIONSHIPS
WITH TEENS AND I ALSO HEARD I
THINK WITH YOUR PROGRAM ON A
TRANSFORMING MEN ARE YOU BOYS
INTO MEN.
ON HOW WE CAN TEACH.
THE BOYS ABOUT HOW TO TREAT
OTHERS AND AGAIN I DO UNDERSTAND
THAT THERE IT'S NOT JUST BOYS
THAT ARE ARE THE ABUSERS BY
STATISTICALLY THE THERE'S A HIGH
PERCENTAGE BY I YOUR PROGRAM FOR
THE YOUNG LADIES IS ALSO
IMPORTANT CELL.
I WANT TO ENCOURAGE EVERYONE TO
SHARE THAT INFORMATION I I'M MY
MIND WAS GOING A THOUSAND MILES
PER HOUR WHEN WE WERE TALKING
ABOUT THESE PROGRAMS BECAUSE I
REPRESENT A LIVING COMMUNITIES.
AND IN MY AREA IT'S ELEVEN
SCHOOL DISTRICTS ARE MORE
ACTUALLY A MONEY HAS THREE AND
SO.
SOME OF THESE PROGRAMS I COULD
SEE FITTING INTO TO OUR
COMMUNITIES AND SO IF YOU CAN
PROVIDE THE AT THE YOU KNOW KIND
OF A WHAT DETAILS ON YOUR
PROGRAMS.
WE WILL MAKE SURE THAT THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS GET IT AND
THAT HOPEFULLY WE CAN REACH OUT
TO YOU AND START SOME OF THOSE
PROGRAMS THROUGHOUT THE STATE --
AND I APPRECIATE THE TIME YOU'VE
TAKEN TO PRESENT WITH US TODAY
AND WITH THAT IF THERE'S NO
OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS I
WANT TO THANK YOU AGAIN FOR YOUR
PARTICIPATION AND FOR THE
AUDIENCE FOR BEING HERE.
WE'RE AVAILABLE IF YOU HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS OR ANY THING OUT --
THAT YOU WOULD LIKE FROM THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS WHAT FROM THE
WHAT IS IT THE RESPONSIBLE
ADULTS -- YOU KNOW THE AT TRYING
TO ENGAGE OUR COMMUNITIES YOU'RE
RIGHT WE DO HAVE AXES.
I USED TO HALF A MILLION PEOPLE
IN OUR OUR RESPECTIVE DISTRICTS
THAT WE CAN SEND SOME
INFORMATION TO AND BRING IN SOME
OF THE SCHOOL LEADERS AND AND
HOPEFULLY GET THEM TO TO
IMPLEMENT SOME OF THESE.
PROGRAMS ARE AT LEAST HAVE A
CONVERSATIONS WITH YOU ON HOW
IMPLEMENTED HOW TO IMPLEMENT
THESE PROGRAMS WITHIN OUR SCHOOL
SYSTEM SO THANK YOU AGAIN I
WOULD LIKE TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE FOR YOUR PARTICIPATION
AND I WILL GO AHEAD AND
ADJOURNED THE MEETING AND
HOPEFULLY THEY'LL OF OUR NEXT
MEET.
OUR NEXT MEETING WILL BE IN A
FEW MONTHS I'M HOPING TO TAKE IT
UPAND DOWN THE STATE -- SO BAD
TO ALL OF THE COMMUNITIES --
HAVE THE THE PRIVILEGE OF
LISTENING TO SOME OF THESE
AWESOME PROGRAMS THAT YOU GUYS
HAVE THANK YOU.
OKAY WE'LL GO AHEAD AND THE
GERMAN ADD THANK YOU AGAIN A
VERY EFFICIENT AND VERY
INFORMATIVE I'D -- TEN FIFTY
THANK YOU